This video introduces functions and their
domains and ranges. A function is a correspondence
between input numbers, usually the x values
and output numbers, usually the y values,
that sends each input number to exactly one
output number. Sometimes a function is thought
of as a rule or machine, in which you can
feed in x values as input and get out y values
as output. So, non mathematical example of
a function might be the biological mother
function, which takes as input and a person,
and it gives us output their biological mother.
This function satisfies the condition that
each input number object person, in this case,
get sent to exactly one output person. Because
if you take any person, they just have one
biological mother. So that rule does give
you a function. But if I change things around,
and just use the the mother function, which
sends to each person, their mother, that's
no longer gonna be a function, because there
are some people who have more than one mother,
right, they could have a biological mother
and adopted mother, or a mother and stepmother
or any number of situations. So since there's,
there's at least some people who you would
put it as input, and then you'd get like more
than one possible output that violates this,
this rule of functions, that would not be
a function. Now, most of the time, we'll work
with functions that are described with equations,
not in terms of mothers. So for example, we
can have the function y equals x squared plus
one. This can also be written as f of x equals
x squared plus one. Here, f of x is function
notation that stands for the output value
of y. Notice that this notation is not representing
multiplication, we're not multiplying f by
x, instead, we're going to be putting in a
value for access input and getting out a value
of f of x or y. For example, if we want to
evaluate f of two, we're plugging in two as
input for x either in this equation, or in
that equation. Since F of two means two squared
plus one, f of two is going to equal five.
Similarly, f of five means I plug in five
for x. So that's going to be five squared
plus one, or 26. Sometimes it's useful to
evaluate a function on a more complicated
expression involving other variables. In this
case, remember, the functions value on any
expression, it's just what you what you get
when you plug in that whole expression for
x. So f of a plus three is going to be the
quantity a plus three squared plus one, we
could rewrite that as a squared plus six a
plus nine plus one, or a squared plus six
a plus 10. When evaluating a function on a
complex expression, it's important to keep
the parentheses when you plug in for x. That
way, you evaluate the function on the whole
expression. For example, it would be wrong
to write f of a plus three equals a plus three
squared plus one without the parentheses,
because that would imply we were just squaring
the three and not the whole expression, a
plus three. Sometimes the function is described
with a graph instead of an equation. In this
example, this graph is supposed to represent
the function g of x. Not all graphs actually
represent functions. For example, the graph
of a circle doesn't represent a function.
That's because the graph of a circle violates
the vertical line test, you can draw a vertical
line, and I'll intersect the graph in more
than one point. But our graph it left satisfies
the vertical line test, any vertical line
intersects the graph, and at most one point,
that means is a function because every x value
will have at most one y value that corresponds
to it. Let's evaluate gf two, note that two
is an x value. And we'll use the graph to
find the corresponding y value. So I look
for two on the x axis and find the point on
the graph. If that has that x value, that's
right here. Now I can look at the y value
of that point looks like three, and therefore
g of two is equal to three. If I try to do
the same thing to evaluate g of five, I run
into trouble. Five is an x value, I look for
it on the x axis. But there's no point on
the graph that has that x value. Therefore,
g of five is undefined, or we can say it does
not exist. The question of what x values and
y values make sense for a function leads us
to a discussion of domain and range. The domain
of a function is all possible x values that
make sense for that function. The range is
the y values that makes sense for the function.
In this example, we saw that the x value of
five didn't have a corresponding y value for
this function. So the x value of five is not
in the domain of our function J. To find the
x values in the domain, we have to look at
the x values that correspond to points on
the graph. One way to do that is to take the
shadow or projection of the graph onto the
x axis and see what x values are hit. It looks
like we're hitting all x values, starting
at negative eight, and continuing up to four.
So our domain is the x's between negative
eight, and for including those endpoints,
or we can write this in interval notation
as negative eight comma four with square brackets.
To find the range of the function we look
for the y value is corresponding to points
on this graph, we can do that by taking the
shadow or projection of the graph onto the
y axis, we seem to be hitting our Y values
from negative five, up through three. So our
range is wise between negative five and three
are an interval notation, negative five, three
with square brackets. If we made a function
that's described as an equation instead of
a graph, one way to find the domain and range
are to graph the function. But it's often
possible to find the domain at least more
quickly, by using algebraic considerations.
We think about what x values it makes sense
to plug into this expression, and what x values
need to be excluded, because they make the
algebraic expression impossible to evaluate.
Specifically, to find the domain of a function,
we need to exclude x values that make the
denominator zero. Since we can't divide by
zero, we also need to exclude x values that
make an expression inside a square root sign
negative. Since we can't take the square root
of a negative number. In fact, we need to
exclude values that make an expression inside
any even root negative because we can't take
an even root of a negative number, even though
we can take an odd root like a cube root of
a negative number. Later, when we look at
logarithmic functions, we'll have some additional
exclusions that we have to make. But for now,
these two principles should handle all functions
We'll see. So let's apply them to a couple
examples. For the function in part A, we don't
have any square root signs, but we do have
a denominator. So we need to exclude x values
that make the denominator zero. In other words,
we need x squared minus 4x plus three to not
be equal to zero. If we solve x squared minus
4x plus three equal to zero, we can do that
by factoring. And that gives us x equals three
or x equals one, so we need to exclude these
values. All other x values should be fine.
So if I draw the number line, I can put on
one and three and just dig out a hole at both
of those. And my domain includes everything
else on the number line. In interval notation,
this means my domain is everything from negative
infinity to one, together with everything
from one to three, together with everything
from three to infinity. In the second example,
we don't have any denominator to worry about,
but we do have a square root sign. So we need
to exclude any x values that make three minus
2x less than zero. In other words, we can
include all x values for which three minus
2x is greater than or equal to zero. Solving
that inequality gives us three is greater
than or equal to 2x. In other words, x is
less than or equal to three halves. If I can
draw this on the number line, or write it
in interval notation, notice that three halves
is included. And that's because three minus
2x is allowed to be zero, I can take the square
root of zero, that's just zero. And that's
not a problem. Finally, let's look at a more
complicated function that involves both the
square root and his denominator. Now there
are two things I need to worry about. I need
the denominator to not be equal to zero, and
I need the stuff inside the square root sign
to be greater than or equal to zero. from
our earlier work, we know the first condition
means that x is not equal to three, and x
is not equal to one. And the second condition
means that x is less than or equal to three
halves. Let's draw both of those conditions
on the number line. x is not equal to three
and x is not equal to one means we've got
everything except those two dug out points.
And the other condition x is less than or
equal to three halves means we can have three
halves, and everything to the left of it not
to be in our domain. And to be legit for our
function, we need both of these conditions
to be true. So I'm going to connect these
conditions with an and and that means we're
looking for numbers on the number line that
are colored both red and blue. So I'll draw
that above and purple. So that's everything
from three halves to one, I have to dig out
one because one was a problem for the denominator.
And then I can continue for all the things
that are colored both both colors red and
blue. So my final domain is going to be let's
see negative infinity, up to but not including
one together with one, but not including it
to three halves, and I include three half
since that was colored both red and blue.
Also, in this video, we talked about functions,
how to evaluate them, and how to find domains
and ranges. This video is a brief introduction
to increasing and decreasing functions based
on their graphs. In this first example, I've
graphed two lines, the first line is an increasing
function. Because as the x values go from
left to right, the y values are going up.
this can be written more formally, by saying
if x two is bigger than x one, these are supposed
to be x values. So that means that x two is
some x value, that's to the right so that
it's bigger than x one. So whenever we have
an x value x to this bigger than x one, increasing
means that f of x two has to be bigger than
f of x one, so that the y values are getting
bigger when the x values are bigger. The second
line is an example of a decreasing function.
Because here as the x values increased from
left to right, the y values are going down.
So again, we can write this more formally
by saying that whenever we have an x value
x two that's bigger than x one, for example,
this might be x two, and this might be x one,
then the y value f of x two is less than f
of x one this time, because here, when we
have a bigger x value, we want to have a smaller
y value to be decreasing. This second example
gives the graph of a function that's increasing
in some places, but decreasing and others.
This part of the graph, here the functions
decreasing, because as the x values increased
from left to right, the y values go down.
Over here, we also have a part of the graph
where the function is decreasing. Now this
part of the graph, the function is increasing,
because as x goes from left to right, the
y values are going up. I've marked that one
in green, for increasing. And finally, on
this part of the graph, the functions are
neither increasing nor decreasing, it's completely
flat or constant. Now we're asked to describe
the intervals on which the graph is increasing
or decreasing. So we describe those intervals
in terms of the x values. It wouldn't make
sense to describe them in terms of the y values
because the y values can be the same for different
parts of the graph, but the x values are always
unique. Describe where this function is decreasing.
That's for x values between negative four
and negative two, and between four and seven.
I can write this using inequalities as negative
for less than x less than negative two, for
less than x less than seven. It's not important
whether I use less than or less than or equal
to signs here, I'm going to use less than
or equal to signs at the endpoints of the
functions domain where the function stops
existing altogether. And I'll use strict less
than signs just where the function starts
or stops decreasing in the middle of its domain.
But again, that's not important. Describe
where the function is increasing. That's for
x values in between negative two, and one.
So I can write that as an inequality as negative
two less than x less than one, I can also
describe these intervals in interval notation.
So that would be close bracket, negative four,
negative to open bracket, a cup sign for union,
and then four comma seven, for the decreasing
part, and the increasing part is negative
two, comma one, I'm going to modify my graph
just a little bit. Now by putting arrows on
the end, what I have arrows instead of dots
are just hard stops, that signifies that the
function continues in the same direction forever.
So if I write it like that, then the place
where the function is increasing is still
the same, it's still going to be from x values
going from negative two to one. But now the
decreasing part of the function extends further.
So this section, these x values extend all
the way out to infinity in it, we assume that
it keeps going keeps decreasing here. So I
would write that as for infinity, and similar
the the left part, I would write as negative
infinity, negative two, because the function
is going on forever in this direction to set
x values go all the way to negative infinity
on that chunk. So when talking about increasing
and decreasing parts of functions based on
graphs, the thing to remember is that x is
going to be heading from left to right. As
long as you do that, increasing just means
that y goes up. Decreasing means that y goes
down. And if you're after describing the intervals,
you have to do that in terms of x values.
This video is about identifying maximums and
minimums for functions from their graphs.
We'll start with some definitions. A function
f of x has an absolute maximum at the x value
of x equals C, if the y value at x equals
C is as big as it ever gets. We can write
this more precisely by saying that f of c,
that's the y value at x equals C is bigger
than or equal to f of x, that's the y value
at some other x value for all x values in
the domain of f, that biggest y value f a
c is called the absolute maximum value for
F. And the point with an x value and a y value
given is called an absolute maximum point.
If I have a graph of a function, then the
absolute maximum value, f of c is the highest
value that function ever achieves. And the
absolute maximum point is the point where
it achieves that value. Now it's possible
for a function to have more than one absolute
maximum point, if there happens to be a tie
where that highest value is achieved. But
a function can only have at most one absolute
maximum value. function f of x has an absolute
minimum at x equals C. If the y value at x
equals C is as small as it ever gets. We can
write this more precisely by saying that f
of c is less than or equal to f of x for all
x values in the domain of f. the y value f
of c is called the absolute minimum value
of f. And the point c f of c is called an
absolute minimum point in the graph of f of
x. f of c is now The lowest y value that the
graph ever achieves. And the point c f of
c is the point where it achieves this very
low y value. For example, this function has
an absolute minimum value of about negative
eight, and it has an absolute minimum point
with coordinates, three, negative eight. If
this function stops here, and has domain from
x values just from zero to four, then the
function will have an absolute maximum value
of 10, achieved at the point with coordinates
for 10. If however, the function keeps going
on forever, then it will have no absolute
maximum value at all. absolute maximum minimum
values can also be called global maximum and
minimum values. A function f of x has a local
maximum at x equals C. If the y value at the
x value of c is bigger than any y values nearby,
it doesn't have to be the biggest y value
anywhere in the domain. For example, for this
function, there's bigger y values up here,
it just has to be the biggest y value nearby,
or more precisely, in an open interval of
X values around C. We can write this by saying
that f of c is bigger than or equal to f of
x for all x values, and an open interval around
C, the y value f OC is called a local maximum
value for F. And the point with coordinates
c f OC is called a local maximum point, a
function f of x has a local minimum at x equals
C. If f of c is less than or equal to f of
x, for all x values in an open interval around
the y value f of c is called a local minimum
value. And the point with coordinate c f a
c is called a local minimum point. A function
might have many local minimum values. In this
example, assuming that the domain is from
zero to four, we have a local minimum point
at x equals three, because this point here
is the lowest point anywhere nearby. It also
happens to be an absolute minimum point. Turning
our attention to local maximum points. This
function has a local maximum point at one
to say, because this point here is the highest
point anywhere nearby, even though it's not
the highest point anywhere in the domain since
their highest points higher points over here.
So we have a local max point at one two, which
is not an absolute max. different sources
use different conventions as far as whether
the point 410 up here counts as a local maximum
point or not. Some sources do consider it
a local maximum, since it's the highest point
anywhere nearby. But other sources say that
it doesn't count as a local maximum, for the
technical reason that you can't get an open
interval values around four because the function
is not defined in an open interval around
four because it's domain stops at four. So
I'll just write this as a caution that some
sources do not consider for 10 to be a local
max point, because f is not defined. In an
open interval around x equals four, local
maximum and minimum values can also be called
relative maximum and minimum values. Please
pause the video for a moment to mark all local
maximum minimum points on the graph of this
function, as well as all absolute max and
min points. The function has a local max point
here at the point with coordinates approximately
say 2.7 3.3 It's a local max point because
it's the highest point anywhere nearby. There's
a local min point right here at the point
with coordinates to to, since this is the
lowest point anywhere nearby. If this point
actually existed, it would also be a local
main points as well as an absolute min point.
But this drilled out circle means that point
is not actually part of the graph. So there's
no local min point here, and no absolute min
points. The point here with coordinates 04,
is considered by some sources to be a local
max point, but by other sources is not considered
a local max point. Since the function is not
defined in an open interval around zero, turning
our attention to absolute maximum and points
while there's no absolute max points as the
function keeps going up and up and up forever.
There's also no absolute min points, because
the function just keeps going down and down
a little by little and never actually achieves
a lowest value. Now if we're talking about
local maximum values, that's just the y values
of the local maxima endpoints. So there's
a local max value at this y value of 3.3.
And there's a local min value of two this
points y value. There are no absolute max
or min values for this function. In this video,
we defined absolute and local, max and min
points and values. This video is about symmetry
of graphs and functions. We say that a graph
is symmetric with respect to the x axis, if
the graph has mirror symmetry, with the x
axis as the mirror line. This graph here is
an example. Here is the mirror line. Notice
that the point five three is on this graph.
And so it's mirror image, five, negative three
is also on the graph. Similarly, the point
two, two is on the graph and its mirror image,
two, negative two is on the graph. For any
point x, y on a graph, its mirror image when
you flip over the x axis will have coordinates
the same x coordinate and the opposite of
the y coordinates. Therefore, we can say that
a graph is symmetric with respect to the x
axis. If whenever a point x, y is on the graph,
the point x negative y is also on the graph.
We say that a graph is symmetric with respect
to the y axis, if it has mirror symmetry,
with the y axis as the mirror line. This graph
is symmetric with respect to the y axis, here
is the mirror line. Notice that the point
with coordinates two three is on this graph.
Its mirror image, which is also on the graph
has coordinates negative two, three, so the
same y coordinate, but the opposite x coordinate.
And in fact, if I take any point with coordinates
x, y, and I want its mirror image with the
y axis as a mirror line, I'm going to get
the point with the same height the same y
coordinate, but the opposite x coordinate.
So I can say that a graph is symmetric with
respect to the y axis. If whenever a point
x, y is on the graph, the point negative x,
y is also on the graph. Finally, a graph is
symmetric with respect to the origin if it
has 180 degree rotational symmetry around
the origin. This means that if I spin it by
180 degrees, the graph should line up exactly
with itself. Rotating a graph by 180 degrees
is the same thing as turning it upside down.
So one way to see if a graph has symmetry
respect to the origin, is to turn it upside
down and see if it looks exactly the same.
This one does. playing around with points,
I noticed that the point one, negative two
is on this graph. If I rotate that point around
the origin by 180 degrees, I get to the point
with coordinates negative one, two. If I start
with a point on the graph with coordinates,
two, three, And I rotate by 180 degrees, I
get the point with coordinates negative two,
negative three. And in general, if I start
with a point x, y, and I rotate that 180 degrees
around the origin, I get the point with coordinates
negative x, negative y. so we can say that
a graph is symmetric with respect to the origin.
If whenever a point x, y is on the graph,
the point negative x negative y is also on
the graph. Please pause the video for a moment
and decide which of these graphs are symmetric
with respect to the x axis, the y axis and
the origin. Some graphs may have more than
one type of symmetry. Graph a is symmetric
with respect to the origin. Because if you
rotate it by 180 degrees, that is you turn
it upside down, it looks exactly the same.
It does not have any mirror symmetry, so it's
not symmetric with respect to the x axis or
the y axis. Graph B does have mirror symmetry,
I'll draw on the two mirror lines. So it's
both symmetric with respect to the x axis
and symmetric with respect to the y axis.
It also looks exactly the same upside down.
So it's also symmetric with respect to the
origin. Graph C is symmetric with respect
to the y axis, but has no other symmetry.
And graph D is symmetric with respect to the
x axis with no other symmetry. We use the
words even and odd to describe functions whose
graphs have certain kinds of symmetry. A function
is even if its graph is symmetric, with respect
to the y axis. Remember that being symmetric
with respect to the y axis means that whenever
a point x, y is on the graph, its mirror image,
negative x, y is also on the graph. That is,
the y values corresponding to x and negative
x are the same. Using function notation, I
can write these points as the points with
coordinates x, f of x and negative x, f of
negative X, since the y value for a function
is given by f of its x value. So we can say
that a function f of x is even if F of negative
X equals f of x, for all x values in its domain,
the function has the same height at x and
negative x. For example, we can see the function
f of x equals x squared plus three is even.
And one way to see this is by looking at its
graph, which looks pretty much like the graph
I've drawn. And that is saying that this graph
is symmetric across the y axis. But we can
also check that this function is even algebraically.
without knowing anything about this graph,
all we have to do is check that F of negative
X is equal to f of x. So if we plug in at
negative x for x into this formula, that's
negative x squared plus three, but negative
x squared is the same thing as x squared.
And so this is exactly the same thing as f
of x. And the property of being even is satisfied.
We say that a function f of x is odd, if its
graph is symmetric with respect to the origin.
Recall that a graph is symmetric with respect
to the origin means that whenever a point
x, y is on the graph, it's 180 80 degree rotated
point, negative x, negative y is also on the
graph. That is the graph y value at x. And
the graphs y value at negative x are the opposites
of each other, same magnitude but opposite
sign. If we use function notation, for the
coordinates of these points, this one is x,
f of x, and this one is negative x, f of negative
x, right because the y value for a function
at the x value of negative x is just F of
negative X. So for a function to be odd, we
see that F of negative X, that y value has
to be the opposite of f of x, the other guys
y value. A function f of x is odd if F of
negative X is the negative of f of x for all
x in its domain. Let's look at this example.
We could draw its graph and verify the functions
odd by seeing that rotational symmetry around
the order On this graph, but we can also figure
it out algebraically by checking to see if
F of negative X is equal to negative of f
of x. So let's plug in negative x for x in
the formula for F, that gives us five times
negative x minus one over negative x, that
simplifies to negative 5x plus one over x.
And we can see that that is actually the negative
5x minus one over x by factoring out a negative
sign, which is negative f of x. So the property
for being odd holds. In this video, we talked
about symmetry with respect to the x axis
symmetry with respect to the y axis, and symmetry
with respect to the origin. functions that
are symmetric with respect to the y axis are
even functions and functions that are symmetric
with respect to the origin, or odd functions.
There's no word for functions that are symmetric
with respect to the x axis. And that's because
if your graph is symmetric with respect to
the x axis, it's not going to be a function.
This video gives the graphs of some commonly
used functions that I call the toolkit functions.
The first function is the function y equals
x, let's plot a few points on the graph of
this function. If x is zero, y zero, if x
is one, y is one, and so on y is always equal
to x doesn't have to just be an integer, it
can be any real number, and we'll connecting
the dots we get a straight line through the
origin. Let's look at the graph of y equals
x squared. If x is zero, y is zero. So we'll
go through the origin again. If x is one,
y is one, and x is negative one, y is also
one, the x value of two gives a y value of
four and the x value of negative two gives
a y value of four also connecting the dots,
we get a parabola. That is this, this function
is an even function. That means it has mirror
symmetry across the y axis, the left side
it looks like exactly like the mirror image
of the right side. That happens because when
you square a positive number, like two, you
get the exact same y value as when you square
it's a mirror image x value of negative two.
The next function y equals x cubed. I'll call
that a cubic. Let's plot a few points when
x is zero, y is zero. When x is one, y is
one, when x is negative one, y is negative
one, two goes with the point eight way up
here, and an x value of negative two is going
to give us negative eight. If I connect the
dots, I get something that looks kind of like
this. This function is what's called an odd
function, because it has 180 degree rotational
symmetry occur around the origin. If I rotate
this whole graph by 180 degrees, or in other
words, turn the paper upside down, I'll get
exactly the same shape. The reason this function
has this odd symmetry is because when I cube
a positive number, and get its y value, I
get n cube the corresponding negative number
to get its y value, the negative number cubed
gives us exactly the negative of the the y
value we get with cubing the positive number.
Let's look at the next example. Y equals the
square root of x. Notice that the domain of
this function is just x values bigger than
or equal to zero because we can't take the
square root of a negative number. Let's plug
in a few x values. X is zero gives y is 0x
is one square root of one is one, square root
of four is two, and connecting the dots, I
get a function that looks like this. The absolute
value function is next. Again, if we plug
in a few points, x is zero goes with y equals
0x plus one gives us one, the absolute value
of negative one is one to two is on the graph
and the absolute value of negative two is
to I'm ending up getting a V shaped graph.
It also has even or a mirror symmetry. Y equals
two to the x is what's known as an exponential
function. That's because the variable x is
in the exponent. If I plot a few points, two
to the zero is one Two to the one is to two
squared is four, two to the minus one is one
half. I'll plot these on my graph. Let me
fill in a few more points. So let's see, two
cubed is eight, that's way up here. And negative
two gives me 1/4 1/8. Connecting the Dots,
I get something that's shaped like this. You
might have heard the expression exponential
growth, when talking about, for example, population
growth, this is function is represents exponential
growth, it grows very, very steeply. Every
time we increase the x coordinate by one we
double the y coordinate. We could also look
at a function like y equals three dx, or sometimes
y equals e to the x, where E is just a number
about 2.7. These functions look very similar.
It's just the bigger base makes us rise a
little more steeply. Now let's look at the
function y equals one over x. It's not defined
when x is zero, but I can plug in x equals
one half whenever one half is two. Whenever
one is one, and one over two is one half,
by connect the dots, I get this shape in the
first quadrant, but I haven't looked at negative
values of x, when x is negative, whenever
negative one is negative one, whenever negative
half is negative two, and I get a similar
looking piece in the third quadrant. This
is an example of a hyperbola. And it's also
an odd function, because it has that 180 degree
rotational symmetry, if I turn the page upside
down, it'll look exactly the same. Finally,
let's look at y equals one over x squared.
Again, it's not defined when x is zero, but
I can plug in points like one half or X, let's
see one over one half squared is one over
1/4, which is four. And one over one squared,
one over two squared is a fourth, it looks
pretty much like the previous function is
just a little bit more extreme rises a little
more steeply, falls a little more dramatically.
But for negative values of x, something a
little bit different goes on. For example,
one over negative two squared is just one
over four, which is a fourth. So I can plot
that point there, and one over negative one
squared, that's just one. So my curve for
negative values of x is gonna lie in the second
quadrant, not the third quadrant. This is
an example of an even function because it
has perfect mirror symmetry across the y axis.
These are the toolkit functions, and I recommend
you memorize the shape of each of them. That
way, you can draw at least a rough sketch
very quickly without having to plug in points.
That's all for the graphs of the toolkit functions.
If we change the equation of a function, then
the graph of the function changes or transforms
in predictable ways. This video gives some
rules and examples for transformations of
functions. To get the most out of this video,
it's helpful if you're already familiar with
the graph of some typical functions, I call
them toolkit functions, like y equals square
root of x, y equals x squared, y equals the
absolute value of x and so on. If you're not
familiar with those graphs, I encourage you
to watch my video called toolkit functions
first, before watching this one. I want to
start by reviewing function notation. If g
of x represents the function, the square root
of x, then we can rewrite these expressions
in terms of square roots. For example, g of
x minus two is the same thing as the square
root of x minus two. g of quantity x minus
two means we plug in x minus two everywhere
we see an x, so that would be the same thing
as the square root of quantity x minus two.
In this second example, I say that we're subtracting
two on the inside of the function, because
we're subtracting two before we apply the
square root function. Whereas on the first
example, I say that the minus two is on the
outside of the function. We're doing the square
root function first and then subtracting two.
In this third example, g of 3x. We're multiplying
by three on the inside of the function. To
evaluate this in terms of square root, we
plug in the entire 3x for x, and this square
root function, that gives us the square root
of 3x. In the next example, we're multiplying
by three on the outside of the function, this
is just three times the square root of x.
Finally, g of minus x means the square root
of minus x. This might look a little odd,
because we're not used to taking the square
root of a negative number. But remember that
if x itself is negative, like negative to
the negative x will be negative negative two
or positive two. So we're really be taking
the square root of a positive number in that
case, let me record which of these are inside
and which of these are outside of my function.
In this next set of examples, we're using
the same function g of x squared of x. But
this time, we're starting with an expression
with square roots in it, and trying to write
it in terms of g of x. So the first example,
the plus 17 is on the outside of my function,
because I'm taking the square root of x first,
and then adding 17. So I can write this as
g of x plus 17. In the second example, I'm
taking x and adding 12 first, then I take
the square root of the whole thing. Since
I'm adding the 12 to x first that's on the
inside of my function. So I write that as
g of the quantity x plus 12. Remember that
this notation means I plug in the entire x
plus 12, into the square root sign, which
gives me exactly square root of x plus 12.
And this next example of doing the square
root first and then multiplying by negative
36, so i minus 36 multiplications, outside
my function, I can rewrite this as minus 36
times g of x. Finally, in this last example,
I take x multiplied by a fourth and then apply
the square root of x. So that's the same thing
as g of 1/4 x by 1/4. x is on the inside of
my function. In other words, it's inside the
parentheses when I use function notation.
Let's graph the square root of x and two transformations
of this function, y equals the square root
of x goes to the point 0011. And for two,
since the square root of four is two, it looks
something like this. In order to graph y equals
the square root of x minus two, notice that
the minus two is on the outside of the function,
that means we're going to take the square
root of x first and then subtract two. So
for example, if we start with the x value
of zero, and compute the square root of zero,
that's zero, then we subtract two to give
us a y value of negative two, an x value of
one, which under the square root function
had a y value of one now has a y value that's
decreased by two, one minus two is negative
one. And finally, an x value of four, which
under the square root function had a y value
of two now has a y value of two minus two
or zero, its y value is also decreased by
two. If I plot these new points, zero goes
with negative two, one goes with negative
one, and four goes with zero, I have my transformed
graph. Because I subtracted two on the outside
of my function, my y values were decreased
by two, which brought my graph down by two
units. Next, let's look at y equals the square
root of quantity x minus two. Now we're subtracting
two on the inside of our function, which means
we subtract two from x first and then take
the square root. In order to get the same
y value of zero as we had in our blue graph,
we need our x minus two to be zero, so we
need our original x to be two. In order to
get the y value of one that we had in our
blue graph, we need to be taking the square
root of one, so we need x minus two to be
one, which means that we need to start with
an x value of three. And in order to reproduce
our y value of two from our original graph,
we need the square root of x minus two to
be two, which means we need to start out by
taking the square root of four, which means
our x minus two is four, so our x should be
up there at six. If I plot my x values, with
my corresponding y values of square root of
x minus two, I get the following graph. Notice
that the graph has moved horizontally to the
right by two units. To me, moving down by
two units, makes sense because we're subtracting
two, so we're decreasing y's by two units,
but the minus two on the inside that kind
of does the opposite of what I expect, I might
expect it to to move the graph left I might
expect the x values to be going down by two
units, but instead, it moves the graph to
the right because As the x units have to go
up by two units, in order to get the right
square root, when I then subtract two units,
again, the observations we made for these
transformations of functions hold in general,
according to the following rules. First of
all numbers on the outside of the function,
like in our example, y equals the square root
of x minus two, those numbers affect the y
values, and result in vertical motions, like
we saw, these motions are in the direction
you expect. So subtracting two was just down
by two. If we were adding two instead, that
would move us up by two numbers on the inside
of the function. That's like our example,
y equals the square root of quantity x minus
two, those affect the x values and results
in a horizontal motion, these motions go in
the opposite direction from what you expect.
Remember, the minus two on the inside actually
shifted our graph to the right, if it had
had a plus two on the inside, that would actually
shift our graph to the left. Adding results
in a shift those are called translations,
but multiplying like something like y equals
three times a squared of x, that would result
in a stretch or shrink. In other words, if
I start with the square root of x, and then
when I graph y equals three times the square
root of x, that stretches my graph vertically
by a factor of three. Like this, if I want
to graph y equals 1/3, times the square root
of x, that shrinks my graph vertically by
a factor of 1/3. Finally, a negative sign
results in reflection. For example, if I start
with a graph of y equals the square root of
x, and then want to graph y equals the square
root of negative x, that's going to do a reflection
in the horizontal direction because the negative
is on the inside of the square root sign.
A reflection in the horizontal direction means
reflection across the y axis. If instead I
want to graph y equals negative A squared
of x, that negative sign on the outside means
a vertical reflection, a reflection across
the x axis. Pause the video for a moment and
see if you could describe what happens in
these four transformations. In the first example,
we're subtracting four on the outside of the
function. adding or subtracting means a translation
or shift. And since we're on the outside of
the function affects the y value, so that's
moving us vertically. So this transformation
should take the square root of graph and move
it down by four units, that would look something
like this. In the next example, we're adding
12 on the inside, that's still a translation.
But now we're moving horizontally. And so
since we go the opposite direction, we expect
we are going to go to the left by 12 units,
that's going to look something like this.
And the next example, we're multiplying by
three and introducing a negative sign both
on the outside of our function outside our
function means we're affecting the y values.
So and multiplication means we're stretching
by a factor of three, the negative sign means
we reflect in the vertical direction, here's
stretching by a factor of three vertically,
before I apply the minus sign, and now the
minus sign reflects in the vertical direction.
Finally, in this last example, we're multiplying
by one quarter on the inside of our function,
we know that multiplication means stretch
or shrink. And since we're on the inside,
it's a horizontal motion, and it does the
opposite of what we expect. So instead of
shrinking by a factor of 1/4, horizontally,
it's actually going to stretch by the reciprocal,
a factor of four horizontally. that'll look
something like this. Notice that stretching
horizontally by a factor of four looks kind
of like shrinking vertically by a factor of
one half. And that's actually borne out by
the algebra, because the square root of 1/4
x is the same thing as the square root of
1/4 times the square root of x, which is the
same thing as one half times the square root
of x. And so now we can see algebraically
that vertical shrink by a factor of one half
is the same as a horizontal stretch by a factor
of four, at least for this function, the square
root function. This video gives some rules
for transformations of functions, which I'll
repeat below. numbers on the outside correspond
to changes in the y values or vertical motions.
numbers on the inside of the function, affect
the x values and raise out in horizontal motions,
adding and subtracting corresponds to translations
or shifts. multiplying and dividing by numbers
corresponds to stretches and shrinks. And
putting in a negative sign. correspond corresponds
to a reflection, horizontal reflection if
the negative sign is on the inside, and a
vertical reflection if the negative sign is
on the outside. Knowing these basic rules
about transformations empowers you to be able
to sketch graphs of much more complicated
functions, like y equals three times the square
root of x plus two, by simply considering
the transformations, one at a time. This video
introduces piecewise functions. A piecewise
function is a function whose defined in pieces
by two or more different rules that apply
for different x values. The rule for calculating
this function is you calculate negative x
squared if x is less than one, but you calculate
negative 2x plus three if x is greater than
or equal to one. So if we want to find f of
negative two, well, negative two is less than
one. So the first rule applies. And we compute
f of negative two by plugging in negative
two for x in the first rule, so that's negative
four. Next, we want to find f of one. Well,
one is right on the border in between the
two rules. But because we have a greater than
or equal to here, when x is equal to one,
we apply this rule. And so we could plug one
into the formula, negative 2x plus three sets
negative two times one plus three, which gives
us one as our output. Finally, if we want
to compute f of three, since three is bigger
than or equal to one, the second rule applies.
And we plug three into that role. That gives
us an answer of negative three. To graph F,
it makes sense to also draw the graph in pieces.
First, I'm going to draw the graph of minus
x squared, just x squared would be a problem
opening up, so minus x squared is a parabola
opening down goes through the points negative
one, negative one and one negative one. So
it looks something like this. Now I've drawn
the whole parabola, but the rule actually
only applies when x is less than one. So I'll
keep the part of the parabola when x is less
than one. And I'll erase the part of the parabola
when x is greater than or equal to one. I'll
leave an open circle here, when x equals one
since that point is not included in this definition,
either. Next, I'm going to draw the second
piece, the line y equals minus 2x plus three.
So that's a line with slope negative two,
and intercept y intercept three, so it goes
through this point 03. And then it goes over
by one and down by two. So it goes through
the point one, one, over by one down by two.
And
I can continue and draw this straight line.
Again, we only want part of this graph the
part where x is greater than or equal to one.
So I'll erase the part where x is less than
one, this part here. This time, I'm going
to leave a closed circle, where x is equal
to one, since that point is included on that
graph. When drawing this graph, it's good
to think about what happens when x equals
one the border point, both in the second role,
where we actually include that point. And
in the first rule, where we don't actually
include that point, but we kind of have to
draw it in order anyway to draw the open circle
here. Now the last question asks us if this
function is continuous. The informal definition
of continuity that I'm going to use is that
a function is continuous if you can draw the
whole thing without picking up your pencil.
And this case, we can't, because we have to
pick up our pencil to get from the jump here,
up to here. So this function is not continuous,
it's got a discontinuity when x is one, which
is exactly the border port between the two
rules. Often piecewise functions will have
discontinuities, where they transition from
one role to the next. However, it's possible
to have a piecewise defined function that
has no discontinuity if the two pieces happen
to line up perfectly. For example, if we've
changed the functions definition slightly,
I'll call it g of x this time to still be
the negative x squared when x is less than
one, but this time, negative 2x plus one,
if x is bigger than equal to one, then when
we graph it, The parabola piece will look
the same, but the linear piece will be two
units lower than before. And so it'll actually
start right here at one, negative one and
go down, and our function will be continuous.
That's all for this introduction to piecewise
functions. The inverse of a function undoes
what the function does. So the inverse of
tying your shoes would be to untie them. And
the inverse of the function that adds two
to a number would be the function that subtracts
two from a number. This video introduces inverses
and their properties. Suppose f of x is a
function defined by this chart. In other words,
f of two is three, f of three is five, f of
four is six, and f of five is one, the inverse
function for F written f superscript. Negative
1x undoes what f does. Since f takes two to
three, F inverse takes three back to two.
So we write this f superscript. Negative one
of three is to. Similarly, since f takes three
to five, F inverse takes five to three. And
since f takes four to six, f inverse of six
is four. And since f takes five to one, f
inverse of one is five. I'll use these numbers
to fill in the chart. Notice that the chart
of values when y equals f of x and the chart
of values, when y equals f inverse of x are
closely related. They share the same numbers,
but the x values for f of x correspond to
the y values for f inverse of x, and the y
values for f of x correspond to the x values
for f inverse of x. That leads us to the first
key fact inverse functions reverse the roles
of y and x. I'm going to plot the points for
y equals f of x in blue. Next, I'll plot the
points for y equals f inverse of x in red.
Pause the video for a moment and see what
kind of symmetry you observe in this graph.
How are the blue points related to the red
points, you might have noticed that the blue
points and the red points are mirror images
over the mirror line, y equals x. So our second
key fact is that the graph of y equals f inverse
of x can be obtained from the graph of y equals
f of x by reflecting over the line y equals
x. This makes sense, because inverses, reverse
the roles of y and x. In the same example,
let's compute f inverse of f of two, this
open circle means composition. In other words,
we're computing f inverse of f of two, we
compute this from the inside out. So that's
f inverse of three. Since F of two is three,
and f inverse of three, we see as to similarly,
we can compute f of f inverse of three. And
that means we take f of f inverse of three.
Since f inverse of three is two, that's the
same thing as computing F of two, which is
three. Please pause the video for a moment
and compute these other compositions. You
should have found that in every case, if you
take f inverse of f of a number, you get back
to the very same number you started with.
And similarly, if you take f of f inverse
of any number, you get back to the same number
you started with. So in general, f inverse
of f of x is equal to x, and f of f inverse
of x is also equal to x. This is the mathematical
way of saying that F and envir f inverse undo
each other. Let's look at a different example.
Suppose that f of x is x cubed. Pause the
video for a moment and guess what the inverse
of f should be. Remember, F inverse undoes
the work that F does. You might have guessed
that f inverse of x is going to be the cube
root function. We can check that this is true
by looking at f of f inverse of x, that's
F of the cube root of function, which means
the cube root function cubed, which gets us
back to x. Similarly, If we compute f inverse
of f of x, that's the cube root of x cubed.
And we get back to excellence again. So the
cube root function really is the inverse of
the cubing function. When we compose the two
functions, we get back to the number that
we started with. It'd be nice to have a more
systematic way of finding inverses of functions
besides guessing and checking. One method
uses the fact that inverses, reverse the roles
of y and x. So if we want to find the inverse
of the function, f of x equals five minus
x over 3x, we can write it as y equals five
minus x over 3x. Reverse the roles of y and
x to get x equals five minus y over three
y, and then solve for y. To solve for y, let's
multiply both sides by three y. Bring all
terms with y's in to the left side, and alternate
without y's and then to the right side, factor
out the y and divide to isolate y. This gives
us f inverse of x as five over 3x plus one.
Notice that our original function f and our
inverse function, f inverse are both rational
functions, but they're not the reciprocals
of each other. And then General, f inverse
of x is not usually equal to one over f of
x. This can be confusing, because when we
write two to the minus one, that does mean
one or two, but f to the minus one of x means
the inverse function and not the reciprocal.
It's natural to ask if all functions have
inverse functions, that is for any function
you might encounter. Is there always a function
that it's it is its inverse? In fact, the
answer is no. See, if you can come up with
an example of a function that does not have
an inverse function. The word function here
is key. Remember that a function is a relationship
between x values and y values, such that for
each x value in the domain, there's only one
corresponding y value. One example of a function
that does not have an inverse function is
the function f of x equals x squared. To see
that, the inverse of this function is not
a function. Note that for the x squared function,
the number two and the number negative two,
both go to number four. So if I had an inverse,
it would have to send four to both two and
negative two, the inverse would not be a function,
it might be easier to understand the problem,
when you look at a graph of y equals x squared.
Recall that inverse functions reverse the
roles of y and x and flip the graph over the
line y equals x. But when I flip the green
graph over the line y equals x, I get this
red graph. This red graph is not the graph
of a function, because it violates the vertical
line test. The reason that violates the vertical
line test is because the original green function
violates the horizontal line test, and has
2x values with the same y value. In general,
a function f has an inverse function if and
only if the graph of f satisfies the horizontal
line test, ie every horizontal line intersects
the graph. And at most one point, pause the
video for a moment and see which of these
four graphs satisfy the horizontal line test.
In other words, which of the four corresponding
functions would have an inverse function you
may have found that graphs A and B violate
the horizontal line test. So their functions
would not have inverse functions. But graphs
C and D satisfy the horizontal line test.
So these graphs represent functions that do
have inverses. functions that satisfy the
horizontal line test are sometimes called
One to One functions. Equivalently a function
is one to one if for any two different x values,
x one and x two. the y value is f of x one
and f of x two are done. different numbers.
Sometimes as I said, f is one to one, if,
whenever f of x one is equal to f of x two,
then x one has to equal x two. As our last
example, let's try to find P inverse of x,
where p of x as the square root of x minus
two drawn here, if we graph P inverse on the
same axis as p of x, we get the following
graph, simply by flipping over the line y
equals x. If we try to solve the problem,
algebraically, we can write y equal to a squared
of x minus two, reverse the roles of y and
x and solve for y by squaring both sides and
adding two. Now if we were to graph y equals
x squared plus two, that would look like a
parabola, it would look like the red graph
we've already drawn together with another
arm on the left side. But we know that our
actual inverse function consists only of this
right arm, we can specify this algebraically
by making the restriction that x has to be
bigger than or equal to zero. This corresponds
to the fact that on the original graph, for
the square root of x, y was only greater than
or equal to zero. Looking more closely at
the domain and range of P and P inverse, we
know that the domain of P is all values of
x such that x minus two is greater than or
equal to zero. Since we can't take the square
root of a negative number. This corresponds
to x values being greater than or equal to
two, or an interval notation, the interval
from two to infinity. The range of P, we can
see from the graph is our y value is greater
than or equal to zero, or the interval from
zero to infinity. Similarly, based on the
graph, we see the domain of P inverse is x
values greater than or equal to zero, the
interval from zero to infinity. And the range
of P inverse is Y values greater than or equal
to two, or the interval from two to infinity.
If you look closely at these domains and ranges,
you'll notice that the domain of P corresponds
exactly to the range of P inverse, and the
range of P corresponds to the domain of P
inverse. This makes sense, because inverse
functions reverse the roles of y and x. The
domain of f inverse of x is the x values for
F inverse, which corresponds to the y values,
or the range of F. The range of f inverse
is the y values for F inverse, which correspond
to the x values or the domain of f. In this
video, we discussed five key properties of
inverse functions. inverse functions, reverse
the roles of y and x. The graph of y equals
f inverse of x is the graph of y equals f
of x reflected over the line y equals x. When
we compose F with F inverse, we get the identity
function y equals x. And similarly, when we
compose f inverse with F, that brings x to
x. In other words, F and F inverse undo each
other. The function f of x has an inverse
function if and only if the graph of y equals
f of x satisfies the horizontal line test.
And finally, the domain of f is the range
of f inverse and the range of f is the domain
of f inverse. These properties of inverse
functions will be important when we study
exponential functions and their inverses logarithmic
functions. There are different ways of describing
the size of an angle. This video explains
how to convert between them. angles are commonly
measured using either degrees or radians.
If we're talking about degrees, then a full
circle, by convention is 360 degrees. A half
circle then would be 180 degrees. And if I
wanted to do say, a third of a circle, that
would be a third of 360 degrees or 120 degrees.
If we're using radians instead, then going
all the way around the circle is called two
pi radians. The two pi was chosen because
that's the circumference of a circle with
a radius of one, a half circle is then half
of two pi radians, which is pi radians. And
if I wanted to do say, a quarter of a circle,
that would be a quarter of my two pi radians,
a quarter of two pi is pi over two. To convert
between degrees and radians is handed to us
the fact that 180 degrees corresponds to pi
radians. Both of these represent half of a
circle. Let's convert negative 135 degrees
to radians. Now, you might be wondering, what
does a negative angle even mean? Well, by
convention, if we go in the counterclockwise
direction, that's considered a positive angle.
And if we go in the clockwise direction, that's
considered a negative angle. To convert negative
135 degrees to radians, I could multiply by
pi radians per 180 degrees. Notice that the
degrees cancel here, and I end up with negative
135 pi over 180 radians. That simplifies to
negative three Pi over four radians. Or if
I convert pi to a decimal, that's negative
2.3562 radians, up to four decimal places.
But usually, if the answer is a simple fraction
times pi, it's better to leave it in that
form. Rather than convert it to a decimal.
I can also go the other direction and convert
radians to degrees, five pi over four radians.
Now again, I we need to use the fact that
pi radians is 180 degrees. But if I write
it like this, with radians on the top and
degrees on the bottom, then the radians won't
cancel. So that doesn't work. Instead, so
instead, I need to find by the 180 degrees
over hi radians, so they got cancel the radians
that way left radio cancel, and I get five
pi times 180 over four pi degrees. Now the
PI's also cancel, and this simplifies to 225
degrees. Converting seven radians to degrees
is similar, I need to multiply by 180 degrees
over pi radians. If I work out seven times
180 over pi on my calculator, I get 401 point
O seven degrees up to two decimal places.
Notice that my answer a little more than 400
is more than 360 degrees, so this is more
than a full circle. That makes sense since
seven radians is more than two pi radians.
Since pi is itself a little more than three.
Sometimes angles are given in terms of degrees,
minutes and seconds, as in 32 degrees, 17
minutes, and 25 seconds. A minute is defined
as 1/60 of a degree. A second is defined as
1/60 of a minute, but since a minute is itself
1/60 of a degree This is 1/60 of 1/60 of a
degree, or one over 3600 of a degree. You
can also think of this by saying that they're
60 minutes in one degree and they're 3600
seconds in one degree. Let's convert this
number of degrees minutes and seconds to a
decimal number of degrees. We know that we
have 32 degrees plus 17 minutes plus 25 seconds.
I'm going to copy down the 32 degrees, but
I need to convert the minutes to degrees.
I know that there's 60 minutes in one degree
If I want the unit's to cancel, I better put
the degrees on the top, so one degree corresponds
to 60 minutes. Similarly, if I want to convert
seconds to degrees 25 seconds, I know that
there are 3600 seconds in one degree, I want
the degrees to end up on the top, and I want
the seconds on the bottom to cancel with a
25 seconds. So I need to write it this way.
Okay, now I can write this as 32 degrees plus
17 over 60 degrees plus 25 over 3600 degrees.
And because the minutes cancelled, and the
seconds cancelled, if I add this all up on
my calculator, I get 32.2903 degrees up to
four decimal places, I can also go the other
direction, and convert a decimal number of
degrees into degrees, minutes and seconds.
I'm starting out with 247 degrees plus a decimal
number of degrees leftover. If I want to convert
0.3486 degrees, two minutes, well, I know
that I have 60 minutes in one degree, this
time, I want the minutes on the top and the
degrees on the bottom, so that my degrees
will cancel. So I just multiply my decimal
by 60. And I end up with 20.916 minutes. Let
me copy this down. And now I'm going to take
the 0.916 minutes and convert those two seconds.
So I know that they're 60 seconds in one minute.
So canceling my units again, I just multiply
by 60, which gives me 54.96 minutes, I can
copy this down as is. Or I can round off my
seconds and get 247 degrees, 20 minutes, and
55 seconds. converting between different ways
of measuring angles is all about unit conversion.
To convert between radians and degrees, we
use the fact that pi radians corresponds to
180 degrees. To convert between minutes and
seconds and degrees, we use the fact that
60 minutes corresponds to one degree, and
60 seconds corresponds to one minute. If you
have a circle, a piece of the circumference
is called an arc. And a wedge of pi for that
circle is called a sector. This video explains
how to calculate the length of the arc and
the area of the sector in terms of the angle
and the radius of the circle. the circumference
of a circle is given by the formula, the circumference
equals two pi times the radius. Let's use
that to solve the following problem. A circular
pool has a radius of eight meters, find the
arc length spanned by a central angle of 2.5
radians. So this angle from the center of
the circle is supposed to be 2.5 radians.
I've drawn the angle is a little bit less
than half the circle because half the circle
would be pi radians, which is 3.141 radians.
So I want to find the length of this arc.
I know that the total circumference is going
to be two pi times eight meters. But I just
want a fraction of the circumference. The
arc length I want is going to be given by
the fraction of the circle that the angle
makes times the circumference of the circle.
The fraction of the circle that I want is
given by the ratio of 2.5 radians over the
total number of radians in the circle, which
is two pi radians. Multiply that by there's
a conference, which we said was two pi times
eight meters. Notice that the two PI's cancel,
and I'm left with just 2.5 times eight meters,
which is 10 meters. In general, the arc length
is related to the angle it spans by considering
the arc length to be the fraction of the circle
you get by taking the angle over The total
angle the circle of two pi times the circumference,
which is two pi r. Since the two PI's cancel
as they did in our example, that means that
arc length is given by theta times r. here,
R is the radius of the circle, and theta is
the angle, it's important to note that theta
needs to be measured in radians, not degrees
for this to work. That's because when I took
this ratio, I was using two pi radians for
the total measure of the circle. So it's important
that theta also be in radians. The area of
a circle is given by the formula, pi r squared,
where r is the radius, let's use that fact
to find the area of the sector of a circle
of radius 10 meters. that spans an angle of
pi over six radians, we know that the total
area of the circle is given by pi times 10
meters squared, or 100 pi meter squared. But
we just want a fraction of that area to give
us the area of our sector. So we want to take
the fraction of the circle that the sector
makes times the area of the circle. Well,
the fraction of the circle is given by the
angle of pi over six over the total angle
in the whole circle of two pi. And well times
that by the 100 pi meter squared, that simplifies
to 100 pi over 12 meters squared, or 25 thirds
pi meter squared as a decimal, that's 26.18
meter squared up to two decimal places. In
general, if you want to find the area of a
sector, you can take the fraction of the circle
that the sector spans out times the area of
the circle, pi r squared. Notice that the
fraction of the circle is given by the angle
that the sector makes in radians, divided
by the two pi radians in the circle. Since
the PI's cancel, we can simplify this formula
by saying the area is given by theta over
two times r squared, where theta is the angle
of the sector in radians. Again, it's important
that this angle be in radians, since that's
how we're doing our fraction of our circle
comparison. As usual, r represents the radius
of the circle. Notice that if you don't have
your angle in radians, if it's in degrees
instead, not a big deal, because we can always
convert from degrees to radians first, before
using our formula. In this video, we saw that
for our sector of angle theta, given in radians,
the arc length is given by the formula theta
times R. And the area of the sector is given
by theta over two times r squared, where r
is the radius of the circle. This video defines
linear and radial speed for a rotating circle,
and explains how to convert between them.
Consider a spinning wheel. The angular speed
is the angle it goes through in a unit of
time, I can write that as angle per time,
the units will be something like radians per
second if the angle is measured in radians,
and the time is measured in seconds, or I
guess we could do degrees per minute, etc.
The linear speed is the speed of a point on
the rim of the wheel. So that is the distance
a point on the rim of the wheel travel travels
in a unit of time. I can think of that as
distance per time. And so it has units of
something like meters per second for example,
or it could be feet per minute, etc. Suppose
we have a ferris wheel with radius 20 meters.
That's making one revolution every two minutes,
we want to find its angular speed and the
linear speed of a point on its rim. Now the
Ferris wheel is going one revolution every
two minutes. So that's one half revolution
per minute, I want to, I want to find the
angular speed, which is the angle it goes
through in a unit of time. I've already got
a unit of time in the denominator minutes,
but I've got to somehow convert revolutions
to angle. So my angular speed, one half revolutions
per minute, one revolution, but that on the
bottom, so the units will cancel out. One
revolution is going through an angle of two
pi radians. That means my angular speed is
going to be one half times two pi radians
per minute, or pi radians per minute. The
linear speed, the speed of a point on the
rim, well, the wheel is going pi radians per
minute, I got to somehow convert radians into
distance. So I know that when I go to pi radians,
so that's all the way around the circle, I'm
going all the way around the circumference
and distance, so that would be two pi times
the radius, or two pi times 20 meters. The
two PI's cancel as do the radians, and I'm
left with 20 pi meters per minute. Let's review
how we got from angular speed to linear speed
in order to get a more general formula. I'll
call the angular speed, omega looks like a
W, I'll call the linear speed v. In the previous
problem, we found the linear speed v, by starting
with the angular speed omega, and multiplying
it by the circumference divided by two pi.
That's because the point on the rim travels
the whole circumference as it goes through
an angle of two pi all the way around the
circle. So I'll write that down here, circumference
over two pi. But since I know that my circumference
is given by the formula two pi r, and the
two PI's cancel, as they did in the previous
problem, that shows that the linear speed
is the angular speed times r, where r is the
radius of the circle. In this video, we defined
linear speed and radial speed, and found that
linear speed was radial speed times the radius
of the circle. This video introduces the trig
functions, sine, cosine, tangent, secant,
cosecant, and cotangent. For right triangles.
For a right triangle, with sides of length
A, B, and C angle theta as drawn, we define
sine of theta as the length of the opposite
side over the hypothesis, the side that's
opposite to our angle theta has measure a
and I have partners is this side here with
measure C. So that would be a oversee for
this triangle. Cosine of theta is defined
as the length of the adjacent side, over the
length of hi partners. This side here is the
side adjacent to theta. Of course, the hypothesis
is also adjacent to theta, but it's special
as a partner, so we don't think of it as the
adjacent side. So that would be B oversea.
tangent of theta is the opposite side length
over the adjacent side length, so that would
be a over b. The pneumonic to remember this
is so toa, that's sine is opposite over hypotenuse.
Cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse. And tangent
is opposite over adjacent. In fact, there's
a relationship between tangent and sine and
cosine. Namely, tangent of theta is equal
to sine of theta over cosine of theta. If
you want to see why that's that's because
some of theta over cosine of theta is given
by a sine, which is opposite over hypothesis,
divided by cosine, which is adjacent over
hypotenuse. If we compute these fractions
by flipping and multiplying, the high partners,
length cancels, and we just get opposite over
adjacent, which is, by definition, tangent
of theta. There are three more trig functions
that are defined in terms of sine, cosine
and tangent. First of all, their sequence
of theta, by definition, that's one over cosine
of theta. So it's going to be one over the
adjacent over the partners, which is the high
partners over the adjacent, which in this
triangle is C over B. cosecant of theta is
defined as one over sine theta. So that's
one over the opposite over the hypotenuse,
which is the hypothesis over the opposite.
And for this triangle, that's going to be
C over a. Finally, cotangent of theta is defined
as one over tan theta. So that's going to
be one over opposite over adjacent, flip and
multiply, I get adjacent over opposite, which
in this case is b over a. So notice that the
values for cotangent cosecant and secant are
the reciprocals of the values for tangent,
sine and cosine, respectively. Let's use these
definitions to find the exact values of all
six trig functions for the angle theta in
this triangle. I'll start with a sine of theta.
That's the opposite of our hypothesis. Well,
for this angle theta, the opposite side is
down here and has measured to the high partners
has measured five, sine theta is two over
five. Cosine theta is adjacent over hypotenuse,
but I don't know the value of the side length.
But fortunately, I can find it using Bagaran
theorem says I have a right triangle here,
I know that a squared, I'll call the side
length A plus B squared, where b is this other
leg of the triangle is equal to c squared,
where c is the hypothesis. So here I have
a squared plus two squared equals five squared,
which means that a squared plus four equals
25. A squared is 21. So A is plus or minus
the square root of 21. But since I'm talking
about the length of a side of a triangle,
I can just use the positive answer. Returning
to my computation of cosine theta, I can write
it as adjacent, which is the square root of
21. Over high partners, which is five, tangent
theta is the opposite over the adjacent, so
that's going to be two over the square root
of 21. To compute secant of theta, that's
one over cosine theta, so that's going to
be one over square root of 21 over five, which
is five over the square root of 21. The reciprocal
of my cosine value. cosecant theta is one
over sine theta, that's going to be the reciprocal
of my sine, so five halves, and cotangent
theta is one over tan theta, so it's going
to be the reciprocal of my 10 value square
root of 21. Over to finally, we'll do an application.
So if we have a kite that's flying at an angle
of elevation as the angle from the horizontal
of 75 degrees, with a kite length string of
100 meters, we want to find out how high it
is I'll call the height Why? Well, we want
to relate the known quantities this angle,
and this hypothesis, to the unknown quantity,
the unknown quantity is the opposite side
of our triangle. So if we use sine of theta
equals opposite of our hypothesis, then we
can relate these known amounts sine of 75
degrees to our unknown amount y, which is
the opposite and our note amount of 100 meters.
solving for y This gives that y is 100 meters
times sine of 75 degrees. We can use a calculator
to compute sine of 75 degrees. Be sure Use
degree mode and not radian mode when you type
in the 75. When I do the computation, I get
a final answer of 96.59 meters up to two decimal
places. Notice that we're ignoring the height
of the person in this problem. To remember
the definitions of the trig functions, you
can use the pneumonic, so tau, and the fact
that secant is the reciprocal of cosine cosecant
the reciprocal of sine and cotangent the reciprocal
of tangent. In this video, I'll use geometry
to compute the sine and cosine of a 30 degree
angle, a 45 degree angle and a 60 degree angle.
One way to compute the sine of a 45 degree
angle is to use a right triangle with a 45
degree angle. This particular right triangle
has I have hotness of length one. Since all
the angles of the triangle have to add up
to 180 degrees, and we already have 90 degrees
and 45 degrees, the remaining angle must also
be 45 degrees. So we have an isosceles triangle
with two sides the same length, I'll call
that side length a. If we want sine of 45
degrees, let's use this 45 degree angle here,
then sine is opposite over hypotenuse. So
if I can figure out how long this side length
is, I'll be able to compute sine of 45 degrees.
Now the Pythagorean theorem says this side
length squared plus that side length squared
equals I have hot news squared. So we have
that a squared plus a squared equals one squared.
Alright, that is two A squared equals one.
So a squared is one half, and a is plus or
minus the square root of one half. Since we're
talking about the length of sides of triangles,
I can just use the positive square root it's
customary to rewrite this as the square root
of one over the square root of two, which
is one over the square root of two, and then
rationalize the denominator by multiplying
the top and the bottom by the square root
of two. That gives me square root of two in
the numerator, and the square root of two
squared in the denominator, which is the square
root of two over two. So the side lengths
are the square root of two over two. Now I
can figure out the sine of 45 degrees, by
computing the opposite over the hypotenuse.
That's, I'm looking at this angle. So opposite
is square root of two over two hypothesis
one. So the sine of 45 degrees is the square
root of two over two. Cosine of 45 degrees
is adjacent over hypotenuse. That's this side
length over this hypothesis. So that's the
square root of two over to over one again,
what would happen if instead of using this
triangle with hypotony is one, we use this
triangle, also a 4545 90 triangle, but with
hypotony is five, not quite drawn to scale.
Please pause the video for a moment and repeat
the computation with this triangle. This time,
I'll call the side length B. Pythagorean Theorem
tells me b squared plus b squared equals five
squared. So two, b squared equals 25. And
b squared equals 25 over two, B is going to
be the plus or minus the square root of 25
over two, again, I can just use the positive
version. And so B is the square root of 25
over the square root of two, which is five
over the square root of two, rationalizing
the denominator, I get five root two over
two. Now sign of my 45 degree angle is opposite
over her partners, which is five square root
of two over two divided by five. That simplifies
to the square root of two over two as before,
and a similar computation shows that cosine
of 45 degrees is also square root of two over
two as before. This makes sense, because sine
and cosine are based on ratios of sides. And
since these two triangles are similar triangles,
they'll have the same ratios of sides. To
find the sine and cosine of 30 degrees, let's
use this 30 6090 right triangle with hypotony
is one. If we double the triangle, we get
an angle of 30 here, so a total angle of 60
degrees here, and this angle is also 60 degrees.
So we have a 60 6060 triangle. That's an equilateral
triangle. All side length the same. Since
this side length has length one, this side
length is also one. This entire side length
is one, which means this short side of our
original triangle has length one half. Going
back to my original triangle, let's use the
Pythagorean Theorem to find the length of
his longer side x. Pythagorean theorem says
x squared plus one half squared equals one
squared. So x squared plus a fourth equals
1x squared is three fourths. And so x is plus
or minus the square root of three fourths
is the positive version and get the square
root of three over the square root of four,
which is the square root of three over two.
Now using our original triangle, again, let's
compute the sine of this 30 degree angle here.
We know that sine of 30 degrees is opposite
of our hypothesis. The opposite of this angle
is one half and the hypothesis is one. So
we get a sine of one half over one, which
is one half cosine of 30 degrees is adjacent
over hypotenuse. So that's the square root
of three over two divided by one. To find
sine of 60 degrees and cosine of 60 degrees,
we can actually use the same green triangle
and just focus on this upper corner angle
of 60 degrees instead. So sine of 60 degrees.
Opposite overhype hotness, but this time the
opposite to this angle is the square root
of three over two. Cosine of 60 degrees adjacent
over hypotenuse gives us one half. I'll summarize
the results in this table below. Notice that
a 30 degree angle corresponds to pi over six
radians since 30 degrees times pi over 180
is pi over six. Similarly, 45 degrees corresponds
to pi over four radians and 60 degrees corresponds
to pi over three radians. I recommend that
you memorize the three numbers one half, root
two over two, and root three over two. And
the fact that one half and root three over
two go together. And root two over two goes
with itself. From that information, it's not
hard to reconstruct the triangles, you know
that a 4545 90 triangle is an isosceles triangle,
so it must have the side links where the same
number goes with itself. And a 30 6090 triangle
has one side length smaller than the other.
So the smaller side must be one half and the
larger side must be root three over two since
root three is bigger than one and so root
three over two is bigger than one half. Doing
a visual check, you can easily fill in the
angles, the smaller angle must be the 30 degree
angle, and the larger one must be the 60 degree
one. In this video, we computed the sine and
cosine of three special angles 30 degrees,
45 degrees, and 60 degrees. This video defined
sine and cosine in terms of points on the
unit circle, a unit circle is a circle with
radius one. Up to now we defined sine and
cosine and tangent in terms of right triangles.
For example, to find sine of 14 degrees in
theory, you could draw a right triangle with
an angle of 14 degrees and then calculate
the sign as the length of the opposite side
over the length of by partners. But if we
use this method to try to compute sine of
120 degrees, things go horribly wrong. When
we draw this 120 degree angle, and this right
angle, there's no way to complete this picture
to get a right triangle. So instead, we're
going to use a unit circle that is a circle
of radius one. The figure below illustrates
how right triangles and a unit circle are
related. If you draw right triangles with
larger of hypotenuse one with larger and larger
angles, then the top vertex sweeps out part
of a unit circle. Let's look at this relationship
in more detail. In this figure, I've drawn
a right triangle inside a unit circle. The
hypothesis of the triangle is the radius of
the circle, which is one, one vertex of the
right triangle is at the origin. And another
vertex of the right triangle is at the edge
of the circle, I'm going to call the coordinates
of that vertex A, B. Now the base of this
right triangle has length a, the x coordinate,
and the height of the right triangle is B,
the y coordinate. If I use the right triangle
definition of sine and cosine of theta, this
right here is the angle theta, then cosine
of theta is adjacent over hypotenuse, so that's
a over one, or a. Notice that a also represents
the x coordinate of this point on the unit
circle, at angle theta from the x axis, I'll
write that down. For a sine of theta, if I
use the right triangle definition, that's
opposite overhead partners. So b over one,
which is just B. But B also represents the
y coordinate of this point in the on the unit
circle at angle theta. For tangent theta,
if we use the right side triangle definition,
its opposite over adjacent. So that's B over
A, I can think of that as the y coordinate
of the point over the x coordinate of the
point. Now for angles theta, that can't be
part of a right triangle, because they're
too big, they're bigger than 90 degrees, like
now I'll call this angle here theta, I can
still use this idea of x and y coordinates
to calculate the sine and cosine of theta.
So if I just mark this point, on the end of
this line at angle theta, if I mark that to
have coordinates x and y, then cosine theta,
I'm still going to define as the x coordinate
of this point, sine theta as the y coordinate,
and tangent theta as the ratio of the y coordinate
over the x coordinate. When we use this unit
circle definition, we always draw theta starting
from the positive x axis and going counterclockwise.
Let's use this unit circle definition to calculate
sine, cosine and tangent of this angle fee.
In our figure, we have a unit circle. And
these numbers are supposed to represent the
x&y coordinates of this point on the unit
circle at the endpoint of this line segment,
that lies at angle fee for the positive x
axis sign fee is equal to the y coordinate
cosine fee is equal to the x coordinate. And
tangent of fee is given by the ratio of the
two, which works out to negative 0.3639 up
to four decimal places. This video gives a
method for calculating sine cosine and tangent
in terms of the unit circle. Starting from
the positive x axis, you draw the angle theta
going counterclockwise. You look at the coordinates
of the point on the unit circle where that
angle ends. And cosine of that angle theta
is the x coordinate, sine of theta is the
y coordinate, and tangent of theta is the
ratio. This video gives three properties of
the trig function sine and cosine, that can
be deduced from the unit circle definition.
Recall that the unit circle definition of
sine and cosine for an angle theta is that
cosine theta is the x coordinate. And sine
of theta is the y coordinate for the point
on the unit circle at angle theta. The first
property is what I call the periodic property.
This says that the values of cosine and sine
are periodic with period two pi. And what
that means is that if you take cosine of an
angle plus two pi, you get the same thing
as just if you took cosine of the angle So,
when we write this down, we're assuming that
theta is measured in radians. If we want to
measure theta in degrees, the similar statement
is that cosine of theta plus 360 degrees is
equal to cosine of theta, we can make the
same statements for sine, sine of an angle
plus two pi is equal to sine of the original
angle. Here, the angle being measured in radians.
If we want to measure the angle in degrees,
the statement is that sine of theta plus 360
is equal to sine of theta, we can see why
this is true from the unit circle definition
of sine and cosine. This is our angle theta,
then theta plus two pi, the plus two pi adds
a full turn around the unit circle to our
angles, so we end up at the same place, theta
and theta plus two pi are just two different
names for the same location on the unit circle.
And since sine and cosine give you the y and
x coordinates of that point on the circle,
they have to have the same value. Similarly,
if we consider an angle theta, and an angle
theta minus two pi, the minus two pi means
we go the other direction around the unit
circle clockwise, we still end up in the same
place. And therefore, cosine of theta minus
two pi, the x coordinate of that position
is the same thing as cosine of theta, sine
of theta minus two pi is the same thing as
sine of theta, the same statements hold if
we add or subtract multiples of two pi. For
example, cosine of theta plus four pi is still
the same thing as cosine of theta, this time,
we've just gone to turns around the unit circle
and still gotten back to the same place. So
if we want to find cosine of five Pi, that's
the same thing as cosine of pi plus four pi,
which is the same thing as cosine of pi. Thinking
about the unit circle, pi is halfway around
the unit circle. So cosine of pi means the
x coordinate of this point right here. Well,
that point has coordinates negative one, zero,
so cosine of pi must be negative one. If I
want to take sine of negative 420 degrees,
well, that's sine of negative 360 degrees,
minus 60 degrees, which is the same thing
as sine of minus 60 degrees. Thinking about
the unit circle, minus 60 degrees, means I
start at the positive x axis and go clockwise
by 60 degrees that lands me about right here.
And so that's one of the special angles that
has an x coordinate of one half a y coordinate
of negative root three over two. And therefore
sine of negative 60 is negative root three
over two the y coordinate. The next property
I call the even odd property, it says that
cosine is an even function, which means that
cosine of negative theta is the same thing
as cosine of theta, while sine is an odd function,
which means that sine of negative theta is
the negative of sine of theta. To see why
this is true, let's look at an angle theta.
And the angle negative theta. A negative angle
means you go in the clockwise instead of counterclockwise
direction from the positive x axis. The coordinates
of this point by definition, r cosine theta
sine theta, whereas the coordinates of this
point are cosine of negative theta, sine of
negative theta. But by symmetry, these two
points have the exact same x coordinate, and
therefore cosine of theta must equal cosine
of negative theta, while their y coordinates
have the same magnitude, but opposite signs.
This one's positive and this one's negative.
Therefore, sine of negative theta is the negative
of sine of theta. Let's figure out if tan
of theta isn't even or odd function. Well,
we know that 10 of negative theta tangent
by definition, is sine over cosine. Well,
we know that sine of negative theta is the
negative of sine of theta, whereas cosine
of negative theta is cosine of theta. Therefore
We're getting negative sine theta over cosine
theta, which is negative tan of theta. Since
tan of negative theta is the negative of tan
of theta, tan theta is an odd function. The
last property on this video is the Pythagorean
property, which says that cosine of theta
squared plus sine of theta squared is equal
to one. A lot of times this property is written
with this shorthand notation, cosine squared
theta plus sine squared theta equals one.
But this notation, cosine squared theta just
means you take cosine of theta and square
it. This property is called the Pythagorean
property, because it comes from the Pythagorean
Theorem. Let me draw a right triangle on the
unit circle. I'll call this angle theta. So
the coordinates of this endpoint here are
cosine theta sine theta. Since this is supposed
to be a unit circle, the hypothesis of my
right triangle has length one, the base of
my right triangle is just cosine theta, same
thing as the x coordinate of this point. And
the height of my triangle is the y coordinate
of the point sine theta. Now the Pythagorean
theorem says that this side length squared
plus that side of that squared equals one
squared. Since one squared is the same thing
as one, that gives me the Pythagorean property.
But the green property is handy for computing
values of cosine given values of sine and
vice versa. And this problem, we're told that
sine of t is negative two sevenths. And T
is an angle that lies in quadrant three. When
we say the angle lies in quadrant three, that
means the terminal side of the angle lies
here in quadrant three. One way to find cosine
of t is to use the fact that cosine squared
t plus sine squared t is equal to one. That
is cosine of t squared plus negative 2/7 squared
is equal to one, I can write this as cosine
of t squared plus 4/49 is equal to one. And
so cosine of t squared is equal to one minus
4/49, which is 4540 nights. taking the square
root of both sides, that goes for the cosine
t is plus or minus the square root of 45 over
49, that's plus or minus the square root of
45 over seven. Now, since we're in the third
quadrant, we know that cosine of t, which
represents the x coordinate of this point,
must also be negative. Therefore, cosine of
t is going to be negative square root of 45
over seven. It's also possible to solve this
problem using the Pythagorean theorem for
right triangles directly. If we look at the
fact that sine of t is negative two sevens
and ignore the negative sign for now, we can
think of this information as telling us that
we have a right triangle, angle theta, whose
opposite side is to and whose high partners
is seven. We call this side here a them but
Tiger in theorem says us a squared plus two
squared is seven squared. So a squared plus
four is 49. So a squared is 45. And a is plus
or minus the square root of 45. Since I'm
worrying about a triangle, I'm going to use
the positive value. Now, cosine of t is going
to be adjacent over hypotenuse. So that's
going to be the square root of 45 over seven.
Now I go back to thinking about positive and
negative signs. And I noticed that since I'm
in the third quadrant, my co sign needs to
be negative, so I just stick a negative sign
in front. This alternative solution uses many
of the same ideas as the previous solution,
and ultimately gets us the same answer. This
video gives three properties of trig functions,
the periodic property, the even odd property,
and the Pythagorean property. This video is
about the graphs of sine and cosine. I want
to graph the functions y equals cosine t and
y equals sine t, where t is in radians. I'm
going to think of this being the t axis, and
this being the y axis. One way to do this
is to plot points. So I'll fill in this chart,
using my knowledge of special angles on the
unit circle. These points will be easier to
graph, if I convert them all to decimals.
Now a plot the points for cosine and connect
the dots to get a graph of y equals cosine
t from t equals zero to t equals two pi. To
continue the graph for t values less than
zero or bigger than two pi, I could plot more
points. Or I could just use the fact that
the cosine values repeat. If I add or subtract
two pi to the my angle T, I'll be at the same
place on the unit circle. So my cosine will
be exactly the same. Therefore, my values
of cosine, which are represented by my y values
on this graph, repeat themselves. For example,
when my T value is two pi plus pi over six
about like here, it's cosine is the same as
the cosine of just pi over six. So I'll take
this dot here and repeat it over here. Similarly,
the when t is like two pi plus pi over four,
I get the same value of cosine is when it's
just pi over four. So this.is going to repeat,
and I can continue repeating all my dots.
This one repeats over here at two pi plus,
say pi over three. And so my whole graph will
repeat something like this. It also repeats
on this side, something like this. Since subtracting
two pi from my t values will also give me
the same value of cosine. We can also plot
points to get a graph for sine and extend
it by repetition. Going forward, I'll usually
write the function sine and cosine as y equals
cosine of x and y equals sine of x. When I
read it this way, notice that x now refers
to an angle, while y refers to a value of
cosine, or sine. That's a different meaning
of x and y, compared to when we're talking
about the unit circle, where x refers to the
cosine value, and y refers to the sine value.
Now let's look at some properties of the graphs
of sine and cosine. The first thing you might
notice is that the graph of cosine and the
graph of sine are super similar to each other.
In fact, you can think of the graph of cosine
as just being the graph of sine shifted to
the left by pi over two. So we can write cosine
of x as the sine function of x plus pi over
two, since adding pi over two on the inside,
move the graph horizontally to the left by
pi over two. Or we can think of the graph
of sine as being constructed from the graph
of cosine by shifting the cosine graph right
by pi over two, that means we can write sine
of x as equal to cosine of x minus pi over
two, since subtracting pi over two on the
inside, shifts the cosine graph to the right
by pi over two. Next, let's look at domain
and range. The domain of sine and cosine is
all real numbers. Alright, that is negative
infinity to infinity, but the range is just
from negative one to one. That makes sense,
because sine and cosine come from the unit
circle. The input values for the domain come
from angles. And you can use any numbers and
angle positive negative as big as you want,
just by wrapping a lot of times around the
circle, the output values for the range, that
is the actual values of sine and cosine come
from the coordinates on the unit circle. And
those coordinates can't be any bigger than
one or any smaller than negative one. So that
gives us a range. As far as even an odd behavior,
you can tell from the graph, here's cosine,
that it's symmetric with respect to the y
axis, and so it must be even. Whereas the
graph of sine is symmetric with respect to
the origin and must be odd. The absolute maximum
values of these two functions is one and the
absolute minimum value is negative one. We
can also use the words midline amplitude and
period to describe these two functions. The
midline is the horizontal line, halfway in
between the maximum and minimum points. Here
the mid line is y equals zero. The amplitude
is the vertical distance between a maximum
point and the midline. You can also think
of the amplitude as the vertical distance
between a minimum point and the midline, or
as half the vertical distance between a min
point and a max point. For the cosine function
and the sine function, the amplitude is one.
A periodic function is a function that repeats
at regular horizontal intervals, the horizontal
length of the smallest repeating unit is called
the period. For y equals cosine of x, the
period is two pi. Notice that the period is
the horizontal distance between successive
peaks, or maximum points, or between successive
troughs, or minimum points. algebraically,
we can write cosine of x plus two pi equals
cosine of x and sine of x plus two pi equals
sine of x to indicate that the functions repeat
themselves over an interval of two pi and
have a period of two pi. In this video, we
graphed y equals cosine of x and y equals
sine of x. and observe that they both have
a midline at y equals zero, an amplitude of
one and a period of two pi. Sine you sort
of functions are functions that are related
to sine and cosine by transformations like
stretching and shrinking and shifting. This
video is about graphing these functions. Let's
start by graphing the function y equals three
sine of 2x. This function is related to the
function y equals sine x. So I'll graph that
first. Now, the three on the outside stretches
this graph vertically by a factor of three,
while the two on the inside compresses that
horizontally by a factor of one half. If instead
I want to graph y equals three sine 2x plus
one, this plus one on the outside shifts everything
up by one unit. Let's compare the midline
amplitude and period of our original y equals
sine x are transformed y equals three sine
2x, and are further transformed y equals three
sine 2x plus one, the original sign has a
midline at y equals zero, an amplitude of
one and a period of two pi. For the transformed
function, y equals three times sine of 2x.
The two on the inside shrinks everything horizontally
by a factor of one half. So it changes the
period of two pi into a period of one half
times two pi, which just pi. Since the two
on the inside only affects x values and horizontal
distances, it doesn't affect the midline,
which is a y value, or the amplitude, which
is a vertical distance. But the three on the
outside does affect these things. Well, in
particular, it affects the amplitude, since
everything is stretched out vertically by
a factor of three, the amplitude of one get
stretch to an amplitude of three. In this
case, the midline doesn't actually change,
because multiplying a y value of zero by three
is still a y value of zero. Now on the third
function, we've taken the second function
and added one on the outside, so that shifts
everything up by one. Therefore, instead of
having a midline at y equals zero, we now
have a midline at y equals one, the amplitude
doesn't change though, it's still three, because
shifting everything up by one doesn't affect
the distance between the mid mine and the
end the maximum point. Also, the period is
still pi since the period is a horizontal
measure, and adding one on the outside only
affects vertical things. Next, let's graph
the function y equals three times sine of
two times quantity x minus pi over four. This
function is very closely related to the first
function we graphed on the previous page,
that was y equals three sine of 2x. In fact,
if we give the name f of x to that function,
and maybe we can call g of x, this other function,
then we can get g of x by taking f of x and
plugging in x minus pi is pi over four in
for x. In other words, g of x is f of x minus
pi over four. This relationship gives mean
idea for graphing g of x the function we want
to graph, we can first graph f of x, we already
did that on the previous page. And then we
can shift its graph to the right by pi over
four, because that's what you do when you
subtract a number on the inside of a function.
So here's the graph of y equals three sine
2x. Recall that it's just the graph of sine
stretched vertically by a factor of three,
and shrunk horizontally by a factor of one
half. Now, to graph the function that I want,
I'm going to shift this graph over by pi over
four to the right. Notice that since I had
my function written in factored form, I could
just read off the horizontal shift. But if
I had written it instead, as y equals three
sine 2x minus pi over two, which is algebraically
equivalent, it would be easy to get confused
and think that I needed to shift over by pi
over two. So it's best to factor first, before
figuring out what the shift is, we're factoring
out the coefficient of x. If instead, we wanted
to graph this function, same as the one we
just graphed, it's just with a minus one on
the outside, that minus one would just bring
everything down by one. Let's take a moment
to look at midline amplitude, and period for
the original parent function, y equals sine
of x, and our final transformed function,
y equals three sine of two times quantity
x minus pi over four minus one, our original
sine function has midline at y equals zero
amplitude of one and period of two pi. For
our transform function, the three on the outside
stretches vertically, so it makes the amplitude
three, the minus one on the outside shifts
everything down by one. So it brings the midline,
y equals zero, down to Y equals negative one,
the two on the inside, shrinks everything
horizontally by a factor of one half. So the
period becomes one half times two pi, which
is pi. Finally, there's a horizontal shift
going on, are transferring function shifts
to the right, by pi over four, this horizontal
shift is sometimes called the phase shift.
The function we just analyzed was y equals
three sine 2x minus pi over four minus one,
which could also be written as y equals three
sine 2x minus pi over two minus one. This
is a function of the form y equals a sine
B x minus c plus d, where b is positive. If
we have a function of this form, or the similar
function with cosine in it, then we know that
the midline is going to be at y equals D.
That's because the original midline of sine
or cosine at y equals zero gets shifted up
by D, we know that the amplitude is going
to be a because this A multiplied on the outside
stretches everything vertically by a factor
of a to be a little more accurate, we should
say the amplitude is the absolute value of
A in case a is negative. If a is negative,
then that amounts to a vertical reflection,
or a reflection over the x axis. We know that
the period of the original sine or cosine
is two pi. And we know that this factor of
B amounts to a horizontal shrink by a factor
of one over B, or I guess it could be a horizontal
stretch by a factor of one over b if b is
less than one. So because we're starting with
a period of two pi, and we're multiplying
by one over B, our new period is going to
be two Pi over B. The trickiest thing is the
horizontal shift. And to get that right, I
like to factor out this be from my equation.
So instead of writing y equals a cosine bx
minus c plus d, I'm going to write y equals
A cosine B times quantity x minus c over b
plus d. Similarly, if it's a sine function,
I write y equals a sine B times x minus quantity
c over b plus d, then I can read off the horizontal
shift as C over B. And that'll be a shift
to the right, if C ever be as positive and
a shift to the left, if C over b is negative,
this might seem backwards from what you're
used to. But it's because we have that minus
sign there. So if C over B is positive, we're
actually subtracting on the inside. So that
shifts right, if C of b over b is negative
minus a negative is actually adding something,
and that's why it shifts it to the left. So
as one final example, say I wanted to graph
y equals 1/3, cosine of one half x plus three
minus five, that would have a midline at y
equals minus five, an amplitude of 1/3, a
period of two pi divided by one half, which
is four pi, and a horizontal shift. But a
rewrite this horizontal shift of six units
to the left, the horizontal shift is sometimes
called the phase shift. And that's all for
graphs of sinusoidal functions. This video
is about graphing the trig functions, tangent,
secant, cotangent and cosecant. To gain an
intuition for the graph of y equals tangent
of x, I think it's handy to look at the slope
of a line at angle theta on the unit circle.
The slope of this line is the rise over the
run. But the rise is given by sine of theta,
and the run is given by cosine of theta. So
the slope is given by sine theta over cosine
theta, which is simply tan of theta. So if
I want to graph y equals tan of x, I can think
of x as being the angle and y as being the
slope of the line at that angle. Notice if
the angle is zero, the slope is zero. But
as the angle increases towards pi over two,
the slope gets bigger and bigger heading towards
infinity. As the angle goes from zero towards
negative pi over two, the slope is getting
negative and heading towards negative infinity,
at exactly pi over two and negative pi over
two, we have a vertical line. And so the slope
is undefined. Using this information, let's
graph a rough sketch of y equals tan x. Remember,
we're thinking of x as the angle and y as
the slope, we're going to go between an angle
of negative pi over two and pi over two. So
we said that the slope was zero when the angles
zero, and then it heads up towards positive
infinity, as we go towards the angle goes
towards pi over two with an undefined value
at pi over two, it goes negative heading towards
negative infinity as the angle heads towards
negative pi over two, also, with an undefined
value at negative pi over two, you can also
verify that for angles slightly bigger than
pi over two, we have the same line as for
angles that are approaching negative pi over
two, and therefore this picture repeats. And
it turns out that tangent is periodic with
period not to pi, like sine and cosine, but
just pi. The period of pi makes sense because
if you take a line and rotate it by 180 degrees,
it's the same line with the same slope and
therefore has the same value of tangent in
this graph of y equals 10x knows that the
x intercepts all right values of x of the
form negative two pi negative pi Zero, pi,
two pi, etc, you can write that as pi times
k, where k is an integer that is a positive
or negative whole number or zero. This makes
a lot of sense because tangent of x is sine
of x over cosine of x. And so you're gonna
get x intercepts, that's where y is zero,
which is where the numerator is zero, and
sine x is zero, at values of the form pi,
two pi, and so on. From the graph, you can
see the vertical asymptotes are at values
like negative three pi over two, negative
pi over two, pi over two, and three pi over
two, these values can be written as pi over
two times k, where k is an odd integer. Again,
this makes sense from the definition of tangent,
since the vertical asymptotes will occur where
the denominator is zero, and cosine x is zero,
at numbers, like negative pi over two pi over
two, three pi over two, and so on, the domain
of tangent is the x axis for which it's defined.
So that's going to be everything except for
the vertical asymptotes, we can write that
as x such that x is not equal to pi over two
times k, for K, an odd integer. The range
or the y values go all the way from negative
infinity to infinity. And the period, as we
mentioned previously, is pi. Since the smallest
repeating unit has a horizontal width of pi,
to graph y equals secant x, I'm going to remember
that secant is one over cosine. So if I start
with a graph of cosine, I can take the reciprocal
of the y values to get the graph of secant,
the reciprocal of one is one, the reciprocal
of zero is undefined, so I'm not going to
have a value at pi over two, negative pi over
two, three pi over two, or negative three
pi over two. When I take the reciprocal of
numbers, just less than one, I'm going to
get numbers just greater than one, but I would
take the reciprocal of positive numbers getting
close to zero, I'm going to get really big
positive numbers going up towards infinity.
Similarly, on the other side, over here, I
have numbers close to zero, but negative,
so their reciprocals will be negative numbers
heading towards negative infinity, the reciprocal
of negative one is negative one. And similarly
here, so I'm getting kind of positive and
negative buckets and upside down buckets as
the graph of my sequence. Notice that secant
has a period of two pi, which makes sense,
since cosine has a period of two pi, it has
a range that goes from negative infinity to
negative one inclusive, and from one to infinity.
That makes sense because the range of cosine
is between one and negative one, and we're
taking the reciprocal of those values. The
domain is everything except for the vertical
asymptotes. Now the vertical asymptotes are
where cosine is zero. So that is at values
of the form pi over two, three pi over two,
etc. That's values of the form pi over 2k,
where k is an odd integer. So the domain is
going to be x values such that x is not equal
to pi over 2k. For K and odd integer. The
x intercepts of secant Well, it doesn't have
any, because you can't take one over something
and get the numbers zero for your y value.
We've seen the graph of y equals tan x and
y equals secant x. This is the graph of y
equals cotangent x. It looks similar to the
graph of tangent x, it's just a decreasing
function instead of an increasing one, and
it has its vertical asymptotes and its x intercepts
in different places. Finally, this green graph
is the graph of y equals cosecant x. It's
related to the graph of sine x, since cosecant
is one over sine x. And in fact, if I draw
the graph of sine x in between, you can see
how it kind of bounces off. Because it's the
reciprocal. I encourage you to memorize the
general shape of these graphs, you can always
figure out the details by thinking how about
how they're related to the graphs of cosine
of x, and sine x. This video is about the
graphs of transformations of tangent, secant
cotangent and cosecant. Before I graph this
fancy function, I'm going to graph the related
parent function, y equals cosecant of x. Recall
that cosecant of x is one over sine of x.
So the graph of cosecant of x has a vertical
asymptotes, where sine of x is zero, that
puts the vertical asymptotes at pi, two pi,
zero, and so on. Because seeing n of x is
one where sine is one. So here, and so it
looks something like this. Now, when I graph
my fancy function, I know that the two on
the outside does a vertical stretch by two,
the plus one shifts up by one, the PI means
everything shrinks horizontally by one over
pi. And so the period, instead of being two
pi, like it is for cosecant, it's going to
be two pi divided by pi, which is two. Finally,
this pi over two has to do with a horizontal
shift. But in order to see by how much we
horizontal shift, we need to factor out the
pie first. So if I rewrite my function, as
two times cosecant pi times x plus a half,
plus one, I can see the horizontal shift is
one half to the left. Let me do those transformations
in pieces. First, I'll do the vertical motions.
So I'll leave the horizontal axis as is I'll
stretch by a factor of two. And now I'll shift
up by one. Next, I'll worry about the horizontal
motion, instead of a period of two pi, I'm
going to have a period of two. But in addition,
everything is going to be shifted left by
one half. So instead of having my vertical
asymptotes at zero, pi, two pi and so on,
they would be at 012, and so on, except everything
shifted over by one half. So that means the
vertical asymptotes will actually be at negative
a half, a half, one and a half, and so on.
Another way to find the vertical asymptotes
is by noting that cosecant is one over sine,
so therefore, cosecant pi x plus one half
does not exist when a sine pi x plus one half
equals zero, ie when pi times x plus one half
is equal to a multiple of pi. canceling the
PI's and solving for x, that's when x is some
number minus a half. So those are exactly
the values of say, one half, three half, five
halves, and so on that we've drawn. So once
we've got the vertical asymptotes in place,
we can see that our graph fits in between
them. This purple piece got shrunk horizontally
and shifted by a half, so it ends up hugging
the x axis. I'll draw it in right here. And
all the other pieces also get shrunk horizontally
and shifted. So my final graph looks something
like this. In this next problem, we're given
the graph and we need to find the equation,
the shape of the graph. And the fact that
it's increasing tells us it must be a tangent
graph. But y equals tan x by itself would
have a period of pi. Let's check what our
graph has a period of need to find the horizontal
width of one complete cycle, it's probably
easiest to measure if I sketch in the vertical
asymptotes, which seem to run from an x value
of negative three to an x value of one. So
that's a horizontal distance of four. So our
graph might be something more like tan of
Bx, where pi over B has to be four. That means
that pi equals four B. And so B is pi over
four. So our graph is probably more closely
related to Y equals tan of pi over 4x. But
if it were exactly y equals tan of pi over
4x, then that middle point right here would
be at the origin. And instead, that middle
point is at negative one, one, that means
my tangent graph is shifted left by one, and
up by one, the left by one, I can accomplish
by writing x plus one, when I have the Pi
over four factored out the up by one I get
by writing a plus one on the outside. Now
as possible, there might also be a vertical
stretch factor out front, an easy way to check
for that is by plugging in x equals zero and
seeing whether what kind of number out in
front I might need to get this y intercept
of two. So I'm going to write y equals a tan
pi over four quantity x plus one plus one,
plug in point 02. So that's two equals a tan
pi over four, zero plus one plus one. And
I can solve for A since tan of pi over four
is just one, this equation simplifies to two
equals a times one plus one, which means that
a has to be one. So in fact, this equation
here is our final answer for this graph. To
summarize, if we have a function of the form
y equals a tan bx minus c plus d, the number
a accomplishes a vertical stretch. The number
B changes the period from pi to pi over B,
the number D shifts vertically by D. And finally,
to figure out what the number c is, we have
to rewrite our equation in factored form factoring
out the B. And so we see that there's a phase
shift right by C over B. The same things hold.
If instead of tangent, we have a graph of
cotangent, we can say the same things for
our graph of secant and a graph of cosecant.
The only thing to be careful of is that B
now changes the period from two pi to two
pi over B, simply because the original period
of secant and cosecant is two pi, whereas
the original period of tan and co tan is just
pi. If you know what the original graphs of
tan, secant cotangent and cosecant look like,
you can use your knowledge of transformations
to graph more complicated functions. This
video defines the standard inverse trig functions,
sine inverse cosine inverse and tan inverse.
In this crazy looking graph, please focus
first on the thin black line. This is a graph
of y equals sine x. The graph of the inverse
of a function can be found by flipping the
graph of the original function over the line
y equals x. I've drawn the flipped graph with
this blue dotted line. But you'll notice that
the blue dotted line is not the graph of a
function because it violates the vertical
line test. So in order to get a function,
that's the inverse of y equals sine x, we
need to restrict the domain of sine of x.
We'll restrict it to this piece that's drawn
with a thick black line. If I invert that
piece, by flipping it over the line y equals
x, I get the piece drawn with a red dotted
line here. And that piece does satisfy the
vertical line test. So it is in fact, a function
of the regular sine x has domain from negative
infinity to infinity are restricted sine x
has domain from negative pi over two to pi
over two. It's, its range is still from negative
one to one, just like the regular sine x.
Because I've taken the biggest possible piece
of the graph, whose flipped version is still
a function. The inverse sine function is often
written as arc sine of x. And since inverting
a function reverses the roles of y at x, it
reverses the domain and the range. So arc
sine of x, the inverse function has domain
from negative one to one, and range from negative
pi over two to pi over two, which seems plausible
from the graph. Now an inverse function undoes
the work a function. So if the function sine
takes angles theta, two numbers, x, then the
inverse sine, or arc sine takes numbers x,
two angles theta. For example, since sine
of pi over two is one, arc sine of one is
pi over two. And in general, the output of
arc sine of x is the angle between negative
pi over two and pi over two whose side is
x. y is equal to arc sine x means that x is
equal to sine of y. But since there are many
angles, y who sine is x, right, they all differ
by multiples of two pi, we specify also, that
y is between negative pi over two and pi over
two. That was the whole point of doing this
domain restriction in order to get a well
defined inverse value. There's an alternate
notation for inverse sine. Sometimes it's
written as sine to the negative one of x.
But this notation can be confusing, so be
careful. In particular, sign to the negative
one of x does not equal one over sine of x.
One over sine of x the reciprocal function
is another word for cosecant of x. But sine
to the negative one of x is another word for
arc sine of x, the inverse sine function,
which is not the same thing as the reciprocal
function, let's go through the same process
to build an inverse cosine function, we start
with a graph of cosine of x, we flip it over
the line y equals x to get the blue dotted
line. But the blue dotted line is not a function.
So we go back and restrict the domain for
our original cosine of x to just be between
zero and pi. The resulting red graph now satisfies
the vertical line test. So it's a proper inverse
function. Our restricted cosine has domain
from zero to pi, and range from negative one
to one. And so our inverse function, arc cosine
has domain from negative one to one, and range
from zero to pi. Since cosine takes us from
angles to numbers, arc cosine takes us from
numbers back to angles. For example, cosine
of pi over four is the square root of two
over two. So arc cosine of the square root
of two over two is equal to pi over four.
arc cosine of x is the angle between zero
and pi, whose cosine is x. In other words,
y equals r cosine of x means that x is equal
to cosine of y. And y is between zero and
pi, since otherwise, there'd be lots of possible
answers for an angle y whose cosine is x.
The alternative notation for arc cosine is
cosine inverse. And again, we have to be careful.
cosine to the negative 1x is not the same
thing as one over cosine of x. one over cosine
of x is also called secant of x. cosine to
the negative 1x means arc cosine On the inverse
function, and these two things are not the
same. Finally, let's look take a look at inverse
tangent function. Here's a graph of tangent,
and black. These vertical lines aren't really
part of the function there, just vertical
asymptotes. So in order to get the actual
function, when we flip over the line y equals
x, we take just one piece of the tangent function.
Here, we've taken the piece marked in black,
we flip that over the line y equals x, we
get this piece in red, which is actually a
function because it satisfies the vertical
line test. Now, you might ask, would it be
possible to pick a different piece of the
tangent function to invert? And the answer
is, yes, we could do that. And on another
planet, maybe mathematicians do that. But
on our planet, we use the convention that
we pick this piece of tangent to invert, which
is kind of a convenient choice since it's
centered here around the origin. In the previous
two examples, our choice of restricted domain
for sine and for cosine was also a convention
that led to a conveniently defined inverse
function. In any case, based on our choice,
our restricted tan function has domain from
negative pi over two to pi over two. We don't
include the endpoints in that interval, because
our restricted tan function has vertical asymptotes
at negative pi over two and pi over two, so
it's not defined there. The range of our restricted
tan function is from negative infinity to
infinity. Therefore, arc tan of X has domain
from negative infinity to infinity, and range
from negative pi over two to pi over two.
Once again, tangent is taking us from angles
to numbers. So arc tan is taking us from numbers
to angles. For example, tangent of pi over
four is one, and therefore, arc tan of one
is pi over four. So arc tan of x means the
angle between negative pi over two and pi
over two whose tangent is x. y is equal to
arc tan x means that x is equal to tangent
of y. And that y is between negative pi over
two and pi over two. The inverse tan function
can also be written as 10 to the minus one
of x. And once again, tan inverse of x means
the inverse trig function, arc tan of x. And
it's not equal to one over tan of x, which
is called cotangent of x. And that's all for
this video on the three basic inverse trig
functions. sine inverse x, also known as arc
sine of x, cosine inverse x, also known as
arc cosine x, and tan inverse x, also known
as arc tan x. This video is an introduction
to solving trig equations. Let's start with
the equation two cosine x plus one equals
zero, I want to find all the solutions in
the interval from zero to two pi, and then
get a general formula for all solutions, not
just those in that interval. Let me start
by rewriting this equation to isolate the
tricky part, which is cosine of x. So I'm
going to write two cosine x equals negative
one, and then divide both sides by two. Now
I'm looking for the angles x between zero
and two pi whose cosine is negative one half.
Since negative one half is one of the special
values on the unit circle, I can use my knowledge
of the unit circle to see that the angle between
zero and two pi must be either two pi over
three, or four pi over three. My answer needs
to include both of these values. There are
no other spots on the unit circle whose cosine
is negative one half. But there are more angles
because we can always take one of these angles
and add multiples of two pi to it. So if I
want to Find all solutions, I can take these
two principles solutions, two pi over three,
and four pi over three, and simply add multiples
of two pi to them, for example, two pi over
three plus two pi, or two pi over three minus
two pi, two pi over three plus four pi, and
so on. A much more efficient way to write
this is to write two pi over three plus two
pi times k, any integer that is any positive
or negative whole number, or zero. Similarly,
I can write four pi over three plus two pi
k, to capture all solutions, based on the
principal solution for pi over three by adding
and subtracting multiples of two pi. This
is my final solution. Next, let's look at
a trig equation involving tangent. As usual,
I'm going to start out by cleaning things
up and isolating the tricky part, which in
this case is tangent. So let me add tangent
to both sides. That'll give me three, tan
x equals the square root of three. And so
tan x is the square root of three over three,
the square root of three over three looks
suspiciously similar to value the value of
square to three over two, which is a special
value on my unit circle. So my suspicion is
that my unit circle will again, help me find
this value of x without a calculator. Recall
that tan x is sine x over cosine x. So I'm
looking for angles on the unit circle between
zero and two pi with a ratio of sine over
cosine will give me square root of three over
three, I actually only need to look in the
first quadrant, and the third quadrant, because
those are the quadrants where a tangent is
positive. And I really only need to look at
angles whose either sine or cosine has a squared
of three in it. So by trial and error, I can
see that tan pi over six, which is sine pi
over six over cosine pi over six, will give
me one half over root three over two, that's
the same thing as one half times two over
three, which is one over root three. If I
rationalize that, I get root three over three.
So that value works. If I try tan of pi over
three, instead, I get root three, which is
not equal to root three over three. So pi
over three doesn't work. Similarly, I can
work out some the values in the third quadrant
and see that seven pi over six works. But
four pi over three does not. So my answer
to part A includes just two values, pi over
six, and seven pi over six. Now if I want
to find all solutions, not just those in the
interval from zero to two pi, I noticed that
I can take one of these principal solutions
and add multiples of two pi to it, because
that'll give me the same angle. So I get pi
over six plus two pi k, and pi over six, sorry,
seven pi over six plus two pi k, any integer.
This is a correct answer. But it's not as
simple as it could be. Notice that seven pi
over six over here on the unit circle is exactly
pi more than pi over six. So instead of taking
both of these and adding multiples of two
pi to them, I could get all the same answers
by just taking one of them and adding multiples
of pi to it. So a more efficient answer is
to say that x equals pi over six plus pi times
k for K any integer. This will still capture
all the same solutions. Because when k is
even, I'll get this family of solutions. And
when k is odd, I'll get this family. For example,
when k is one pi over six plus one times pi
is just the original seven pi over six. If
you think about the fact that tangent has
a period of pi instead of two pi, it makes
a lot of sense that you should be able to
write the solutions in the form. In this video,
we solved basic trig equations by first, isolating
sine, or tangent, or the same thing would
work with cosine. And then using the unit
circle to find principal solutions, Principal
solutions are just solutions between zero
and two pi. And then adding multiples of two
pi to these principles solutions to get all
solutions. For tangent, we noticed that it
was equivalent to just use one principal solution
and add multiples of pi instead of two pi.
In a previous video, we looked at trig equations
that can be solved using the unit circle.
In this video, we'll solve trig equations
that don't involve special values on the unit
circle, and require a calculator instead to
solve. Let's look at the equation two cosine
t equals one minus cosine t. As usual, I'll
start by simplifying and isolating cosine.
Adding cosine to both sides, I get three cosine
t equals one divided by three gives cosine
t equals 1/3. Now 1/3 is not one of my special
values on the unit circle, but I can locate
it approximately cosine represents the x value
of a point on the unit circle. So I'm looking
for a point on the unit circle whose x coordinate
is approximately 1/3. So maybe right here,
and the symmetric angle right here, those
are angles in the first and fourth quadrants.
To get a decimal approximation for one of
these angles, I can take arc cosine of both
sides of my equation. This gives me t equals
arc cosine of 1/3, which, using my calculator
on radian mode, I get a decimal approximation
of 1.2310. Up to four decimal places, it's
important to use radian mode here. Since by
convention, the answers to trig equations
are expected to be in radians unless otherwise
specified. It's also important to notice that
these two equations are not precisely the
same thing. Since cosine t equals 1/3, has
infinitely many solutions if we don't restrict
to a certain interval, and even if we restrict
to the interval zero to two pi, it still has
two different solutions. On the other hand,
our T equals arc cosine of 1/3 has only one
solution. And that solution lies between the
angles of zero and pi. So this angle here,
the 1.231, a radians must be giving us this
angle, so there's got to be an angle between
zero and pi. And to get the other angle this
one, we can use the symmetry of the situation.
This angle and this angle are the same size.
So to get all the way around to here, we can
go all the way to pi minus r 1.2312 radians.
Using our calculator again, we can compute
that two pi minus 1.2310 radians is equal
to 5.05 to two radians. So our two solutions
on our interval from zero to two pi, are given
by 1.2310 and 5.05 to two radians. Let me
emphasize that we found the second solution
by taking two pi minus the first solution.
Now it's straightforward to find all solutions,
we can just take our two principal solutions
and add multiples of two pi. It can be helpful
to look at this solution graphically. To solve
our equation, cosine t equals 1/3. We want
to know where this graph of y equals cosine
of t intersects the horizontal line at y equals
1/3. This intersection point here corresponds
to our first solution of 1.2310 radiance.
This intersection point here corresponds to
our second solution. Notice that it occurs
at a T value, that's two pi minus this T value
here and all the other initial action points
correspond to those first two intersection
points shifted over by multiples of two pi.
Next, let's look at the equation for sine
x minus one equals two. I'll start by rewriting
this as four sine x equals three, which is
equivalent to sine x equals three fourths.
Although three fourths is not a special value
on the unit circle, we can still use the unit
circle to get oriented and see how many solutions
there should be in the interval from zero
to two pi. Since sine represents the y coordinate
of a point on the unit circle, we're looking
for points on the unit circle whose y coordinate
is three fourths. So that might be three fourths
might be about here. So that would be an angle
about right here. And about right here, so
in the first and second quadrants, let's take
the arc sine of both sides to find one of
those angles. I'm getting one of the angles
to be arc sine of three fourths, which my
calculator says is 0.8481 radians, that must
be this angle here. To get the other angle,
I can use symmetry. Since this angle here,
you can get by going up four pi minus my previous
angle, pi minus 0.8481, is equal to 2.2935.
So that's my second angle. Notice that this
time, to get the second angle, we use pi minus
the first angle, not to pi minus the first
angle like we did for cosine. Once again,
we can find all solutions simply by adding
multiples of two pi, we can also locate the
solutions on a graph of sine, we're looking
for where the graph of y equals sine of x
intersects with the horizontal line at y equals
three fourths. And we can see that we have
these two solutions where the second one,
its x value is pi minus the x value this one,
and then we have all these additional solutions
that we can get by shifting over by positive
and negative multiples of two pi from the
first to finally, let's solve the equation
10x equals four. If we simply take x to be
tan inverse of four, which is 1.3258 radians,
we'll get a single solution. But thinking
about the graph of tangent, and intersecting
that graph with the horizontal line y equals
four, we see that there should actually be
two solutions in the interval from zero to
two pi. This makes sense, because the period
of tangent is pi. So any one solution will
get repeated. By intervals of pi. It also
makes sense by thinking about the unit circle.
Tangent, which can be thought of as the slope
of a line at angle theta takes on all positive
real values, both in the first quadrant and
the third quadrant. So there are going to
be two places on the unit circle where the
tangent is for. We've already found this one.
To find the other one, we just need to add
pi. This gives us our answer for the interval
zero to two pi. And we can add multiples of
two pi to get all other solutions. Or if we
want to be more efficient, we can just write
the first solution plus multiples of pi instead
of two pi. Because these two solutions differ
by exactly pi. Taking the first solution,
and then adding multiples of pi will capture
all solutions corresponding to both of these
principal solutions. To summarize, to find
our solutions to cosine t equals m, we need
to find first cosine inverse of m. Then take
two pi a minus this solution and add multiples
of two pi to both of those. To find solutions
to the equation, sine t equals n. We can start
by taking sine inverse of n using pi minus
this and adding multiples of to pi. To find
our solutions to tangent t equals P, we can
take t equal tan inverse of P, and tan inverse
of p plus pi and add multiples of two pi.
Or we can just take 10 inverse of P, and add
multiples of pi. Although the examples that
we saw were more simple than some, because
for the examples, we saw, the inverse trig
function always landed us in the first quadrant,
these methods will work more generally. That's
all for this video on solving trig equations
that require a calculator. This video is about
identities involving trig functions like sine
and cosine. But I want to start with some
examples that just involve quadratic functions.
If I want to find the solutions to this equation,
I can rewrite it x squared minus 6x minus
seven equals zero, factor it, x minus seven
times x plus one equals zero, set the factors
equal to 0x minus seven equals zero, or x
plus one equals zero. And that gives me the
solutions, x equals seven, or x equals negative
one. Next, let's look at this more complicated
equation. I'm going to try to solve that for
x by multiplying out the right hand side.
Next, our combined terms on the right hand
side. So that gives me x squared minus 6x.
On both sides, well, x squared minus 6x is
equal to x squared minus 6x. That's true no
matter what I plug in for x. And therefore,
all values of x satisfy this equation, we
can say that the solution set is all real
numbers. The second equation is called an
identity, because it holds for all values
of the variable. The first equation, on the
other hand is not an identity, because it
only holds for some values of x and not all
values. Please pause the video for a moment
and try to decide which of the following three
equations or identities that is, which of
these equations hold for all values of the
variable. To start out, you might want to
test them by plugging in a few values of the
variable and see if the equation holds. The
first equation is not an identity. It does
hold for some values of x. For example, if
x equals zero, then sine of two times zero
is zero, and two times sine of zero is also
zero. So it does hold when x is zero. However,
when x is say, pi over two, then sine of two
times pi over two, that's the same thing as
sine of pi, which is zero, but two times sine
of pi over two, that's two times one, or two,
and zero is not equal to two. So the equation
does not hold for x equals pi over two. Since
it doesn't hold for all values of the variable,
it's not an identity. The second equation
is an identity. You can build some evidence
for this by plugging in numbers. For example,
cosine of zero plus pi, which is negative
one is the same thing as negative of cosine
of zero. You can also check for example, that
cosine of pi over six plus pi is the same
thing as negative cosine of pi over six. But
even if we check a zillion examples, that's
just evidence, it's not a proof that the identity
holds, we could have just gotten lucky with
the values we picked, we can build a little
bit stronger evidence by looking at graphs,
I'm going to put theta on the x axis in a
pie graph, y equals cosine of theta plus pi.
That's just like the graph of cosine shifted
over to the left by pi. On the other hand,
if I graph y equals negative cosine theta,
that's the graph of cosine theta, reflected
across the x axis, which gives us the exact
same graph. So graphing both sides gives us
strong evidence that this equation is an identity
it holds for all values of theta. Now the
strongest evidence of all would be an algebraic
proof, which we'll do later in the course,
once we have a formula for the cosine of a
sum of two angles. In the meantime, let's
look at equation C. It turns out equation
C is an identity. And we could build evidence
for it again by plugging in values for x,
or by graphing the left side and the right
side separately, and checking to see that
the graphs coincided. But for this example,
I'm going to go ahead and do an algebraic
verification. In particular, I'm going to
start with the left side of the equation and
rewrite things and rewrite things until I
get to the right side of the equation. The
first thing I'll rewrite is secant and tangent
in terms of their constituent functions, sine
and cosine. Since secant of x is one over
cosine x, and tangent of x is sine x over
cosine x, I can rewrite this expression as
one over cosine x minus sine x times sine
x over cosine x. I can clean up those fractions
and write this as one over cosine x minus
sine squared x over cosine x. Now, I noticed
that I have two fractions with the same denominator.
So I can pull them together as one minus sine
squared x over cosine x. Next, I'm going to
rewrite the numerator one minus sine squared
x using the Pythagorean identity that says
that cosine squared x plus sine squared x
equals one, and therefore, one minus sine
squared x is equal to cosine squared x just
by subtracting sine squared x from both sides.
So I can replace my numerator, one minus sine
squared x with cosine squared x. And canceling
one cosine from the top and from the bottom,
that's the same thing as cosine of x, which
is the right hand side that I was trying to
get to. So a combination of a bunch of algebra,
and the Pythagorean identity allows me to
prove that this equation is true for all values
of x, it's an identity. The best way to prove
that an equation is an identity is to use
algebra, and to use other identities, like
the Pythagorean identity, to rewrite one side
of the equation, till it looks like the other
side. The best way to prove the net equation
is not an identity is to plug in numbers that
break the identity. That is, make the equation
not true. Now, if you're just trying to decide
if an equation is an identity or not, and
not worried about proving it, then I recommend
plugging in numbers, or graphing the left
and right sides to see if those graphs are
the same. Recall that an identity is an equation
that holds for all values of the variable.
This video states and proves three identities
called the Pythagorean identities. The first
one is the familiar cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta equals one. The second
one says tan squared theta plus one equals
secant squared theta. And the third one goes
cotangent squared theta plus one equals cosecant
squared theta. Let's start by proving that
cosine squared theta plus sine squared theta
equals one. I'll do this by drawing the unit
circle with a right triangle inside it by
the definition of sine and cosine, the x&y
coordinates of this top point r cosine theta
and sine theta, the high partners of my triangle
is one, since that's the radius of my unit
circle. Now the length of the base of my triangle
is the same thing as the x coordinate of this
point. So that's equal to cosine theta. The
height of this triangle is the same thing
as the y coordinate of this point. So that's
sine theta. Now the Pythagorean theorem for
right triangles says this side length squared
plus that sine squared is equal to the hypothenar
squared. So by the Pythagorean theorem, we
have that cosine theta square plus sine theta
squared equals one squared, I can rewrite
that as cosine squared theta plus sine squared
theta equals one, since one squared is one,
and cosine squared theta is just a shorthand
notation for cosine theta squared. That completes
the proof of the first Pythagorean identity,
at least in the case when the angle theta
is in the first quadrant. In the case, when
the angle was in a different quadrant, you
can use symmetry to argue the same identity
holds. But I won't give the details here.
To prove the next Pythagorean identity, tan
squared theta plus one equals secant squared
theta, let's use the first without your an
identity, which said that cosine squared theta
plus sine squared theta equals one, I'm going
to divide both sides of this equation by cosine
squared theta. Now I'm going to rewrite the
left side by breaking apart the fraction into
cosine squared theta over cosine squared theta
plus sine squared theta over cosine squared
theta. Now cosine squared theta over cosine
squared theta is just one. And I can rewrite
the next fraction as sine of theta over cosine
of theta squared. That's because when I square
a fraction, I can just square the numerator
and square the denominator. And sine squared
theta is shorthand for a sine of theta squared.
Similarly, for cosine squared theta. Now on
the other side of the equal sign, I can rewrite
this fraction as one over cosine theta squared.
Again, that's because when I square the fraction,
I just get the one squared, which is one divided
by the cosine theta squared, which is this.
I'm almost done. sine theta over cosine theta
is the same thing as tangent theta. And one
over cosine theta is the same thing as secant
theta. Using the shorthand notation, that
says one plus tan squared theta equals sequencer
data, which, after rearranging is exactly
the identity that we were looking for. The
proof of the third for that green identity
is very similar. Once again, I'll start with
the identity cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta equals one. And this time, I'll
divide both sides by sine squared theta. I'll
break up the fraction on the left. And now
I'll rewrite my fractions as cosine theta
over sine theta squared plus one equals one
over sine theta squared. Cosine over sign
can be written as cotangent. And one over
sine can be written as cosecant. That gives
me the identity that I'm looking for. We've
now proved three trig identities. The first
one, we proved using the unit circle and the
Pythagorean Theorem. The second and third
identities, we proved by using the first identity
and a bit of algebra. The sum and difference
formulas are formulas for computing the sine
of a sum of two angles, the cosine of a sum
of two angles, the sine of a difference of
two angles, and the cosine of a difference
of two angles. Please pause the video for
a moment to think about this question. Is
it true that the sine of A plus B is equal
to the sine of A plus the sine of B? No, it's
not true. And we can see by an example, if
we plug in say, A equals pi over two and B
equals pi, then the sine of pi over two plus
pi is the same thing as a sine of three pi
over two, which is negative one. Whereas the
sine of pi over two plus the sine of pi is
equal to one plus zero, which is one, negative
one is not equal to one. So this equation
does not hold for all values of a and b. There
are a few values of a and b for which it does
hold. For example, if a is zero and B zero,
but it's not true in general. Instead, we
need more complicated formulas. It turns out
that the sine of the sum of two ends angles
A plus B is given by sine of A cosine of B
plus cosine of A, sine of B. The cosine of
A plus B is given by cosine A, cosine B minus
sine A sine Bay. I like to remember these
with a song, sine cosine cosine sine cosine
cosine minus sine sine. Please feel free to
back up the video and sing along with me,
I encourage you to memorize the two formulas
for the sine of a sum of angles and the cosine
of a sum of angles. Once you do, it's easy
to figure out the sine and cosine of a difference
of two angles. One way to do this is to think
of sine of A minus B as sine of A plus negative
B. And then use the angle sum formula. So
this works out two, sine cosine plus cosine,
sine. And now, if I use the fact that cosine
is even, I know that cosine of negative B
is cosine of B. And since sine is odd, sine
of negative b is negative sine of B. So I
can rewrite this as sine of A cosine of B
minus cosine of A sine of B. Notice that this
new formula for the difference is the same
as the formula for the sum is just that plus
sign turned into a minus sign, we can do the
same trick for cosine of A minus B, that's
cosine of A plus minus b, which is cosine
A cosine minus b minus sine of A sine of negative
B. Again, using even an odd properties, this
gives us cosine A cosine B plus sine A sine
B. Once again, the formula for the difference
is almost exactly like the for the sum, just
that minus sign has switched to a plus sign.
Now let's use the angle sum formula to find
the exact value for the sine of 105 degrees.
Now, 105 degrees is not a special angle on
the unit circle, but I can write it as the
sum of two special angles, I can write it
as 60 degrees plus 45 degrees. Therefore,
the sine of 105 degrees is the sine of 60
plus 45. And now by the angle sum formula,
this is sine, cosine, cosine, sine. And I,
from my unit circle, I can figure out that
sine of 60 degrees is root three over two
cosine of 45 degrees root two over two, cosine
of 60 degrees is one half, and sine of 45
degrees is root two over two. So this simplifies
to root six plus root two over four. For our
last example, let's find the cosine of v plus
W, given the values of cosine v, and cosine
W, and the fact that v and w are angles in
the first quadrant. Remember, to compute the
cosine of a sum, we can't just add together
the two cosines. That wouldn't even make sense
in this case, because adding point nine and
point seven would give something bigger than
one and the cosine of something's never bigger
than one. Instead, we have to use the angle
sum formula for cosine. So that goes cosine
of v plus w equals cosine, cosine, minus sine,
sine. Now, I've already know the cosine of
v and the cosine of W. So I could just plug
those in. But I have to figure out the sine
of v and the sine of W from the given information.
And one way to do that is to draw right triangles.
So here, I'm going to draw a right triangle
with angle V, and another right triangle with
angle W. Since I know that the cosine of V
is point nine, I can think of that as nine
over 10. And I can think of that as adjacent
over hypotenuse in my right triangle. So I'll
decorate my triangles adjacent side with the
number nine and the hypotony is with 10. Similarly,
since I know that the cosine of W is point
seven, which is seven tenths, I can put a
seven on this adjacent side and attend on
this side. partners'. Now the Pythagorean
Theorem, lets me compute the length of the
unlabeled side. So this one is going to be
the square root of 10 squared minus nine squared,
that's going to be the square root of 19.
And here I have the square root of 10 squared
minus seven squared. So that's the square
root of 51. I can now find the sine of V as
the opposite over the hypotenuse. So that's
the square root of 19 over 10. And the sine
of W will be the square root of 51 over 10.
Because we're assuming v and w are in the
first quadrant, we know the values of sign
need to be positive, so we don't need to Jimmy
around with positive or negative signs in
our answers, we can just leave them as is.
Now we're ready to plug into our formula.
So we have that cosine of v plus w is equal
to point nine times point seven minus the
square root of 19 over 10, times the square
root of 51 over 10. using a calculator, this
works out to a decimal approximation of 0.3187.
This video gave the angle sum and difference
formulas and use them to compute some values.
To see a proof for why the sum formulas hold,
please watch my other video. Remember the
angle some formulas, those are the formulas
for computing sine of A plus B, and cosine
of A plus B. I like to sing them, sine cosine,
cosine, sine, cosine, cosine minus sine sine.
This video gives a geometric proof of those
formulas. There are many great proofs of the
angle some formulas, but I'd like to share
with you one of my favorites for those who
are interested. Alright, the angle some formulas
up here, so we'll know what we're trying to
prove. To prove these formulas, let me start
by drawing an angle A and angle B on top of
that. Next, I'm going to draw a line perpendicular
to this middle line. And I'm going to extend
the top line until it meets that perpendicular,
making a right triangle. Finally, I'll draw
a rectangle around that right triangle that
just touches its vertices. My rectangle is
now divided up into four right triangles.
And I'm going to choose units of measurement,
so that the high partners of my middle triangle
has length one. Now let's stop for a minute
to think about the angles of these other triangles.
Since the top and the bottom edge of the rectangle
are parallel lines, and this hypothenar is
is a transversal. This angle up here must
have the same measure as a plus b down here.
Also, this skinny angle here must have the
same measure as a down here because this angle
is 180 degrees, minus 90 degrees minus this
angle here. And this angle A is also 180 degrees,
the measure of the angles in a triangle minus
90 degrees minus that same angle. So I'll
label this skinny angle with a. Next, let's
figure out as many side length as we can.
Based on the middle right triangle with high
partners one, we know that this side length
down here must be cosine of B, since adjacent
over hypotenuse is cosine B. Similarly, this
side length here must be sine of B. Since
opposite over hypotenuse is sine of B. Now
we see that sine of B is the hypotenuse of
this right triangle, which means that this
little side here has measure sign a time sign
B. That's because the opposite over the hypotenuse
of this angle has to equal sign a. A similar
argument shows that this side has to have
measure cosine A time sign B. Please pause
the video and take a moment to fill in the
side length of this right triangle. In this
right triangle, you should be getting sine
A cosine B cosine A cosine B, sine of A plus
B and cosine of A plus B. But remember, we
have a rectangle here. So the opposite sides
have equal length. This tells us that sine
of A plus B has to equal sine of A cosine
of B plus cosine of A sine of B, which is
exactly the first angle sum formula. Also,
cosine of A plus B, which is this side length,
is exactly the difference of this side length
cosine A cosine B minus this side length,
sine of A sine B. And that's the second angle
sum formula. So I think that's a pretty great
geometric proof of the angle some formulas.
This video gives formulas for a sine of two
theta and cosine of two theta. Please pause
the video for a moment and see if you think
this equation sine of two theta equals two
sine theta is true or false. Remember that
true means always true for all values of theta,
were false means sometimes they're always
false. This equation is false, because it's
not true for all values of theta. One way
to see this is graphically, if I graph y equals
sine of two theta, that's like the graph of
sine theta, squished in horizontally by a
factor of one half. On the other hand, if
I graph y equals two sine theta, that's like
the graph of sine theta stretched vertically
by a factor of two. These two graphs are not
the same. So instead, we need a more complicated
formula for sine of two theta. And that formula
is sine of two theta is two sine theta, cosine
theta. It's not hard to see why that formula
works based on the angle song formula. Recall
that sine of A plus B is equal to sine A,
cosine B plus cosine A, sine B. Therefore,
sine of two theta, which is sine of theta
plus theta is going to be sine theta, cosine
theta, plus cosine theta sine theta. simply
plugging in theta for a and theta for B, in
this angle, some formula. Well, sine theta
cosine theta is the same thing as cosine theta
sine theta. So I can rewrite this as twice
sine theta cosine theta. That gives me this
formula. There's also a formula for cosine
of two theta. And that formula is cosine squared
theta minus sine squared theta. Again, we
can use the angle sum formula to see where
this comes from. cosine of A plus B is equal
to cosine of A cosine A B minus sine A, sine
B. So if we want cosine of two theta, that's
just cosine of theta plus theta, which is
cosine theta cosine theta, minus sine theta
sine theta by plugging in beta for A and B.
This can be rewritten as cosine squared theta
minus sine squared theta, which is exactly
the formula above. Now there are a couple
other formulas for cosine of two theta that
are also popular. One of them is one minus
two sine squared theta. And the other one
is cosine of two theta is two cosine squared
theta minus one. You can get each of these
two formulas from the original one using the
Pythagorean identity. We know that cosine
squared theta plus sine squared theta is one.
So cosine squared theta is one minus sine
squared theta. If I plug that into my original
formula, which I've copied here, so I'm plugging
in instead of cosine squared, I'm going to
write one minus sine squared theta, I still
have a nother minus sine squared theta. So
that's the same thing as one minus Twice science
grade data, which is exactly what I'm looking
for. Similarly, I can use the Pythagorean
identity to write sine squared theta as one
minus cosine squared theta. Again, I'll take
this equation and copy it below. But this
time, I'm going to plug in for sine squared
right here. So that gives me cosine of two
theta is cosine squared theta minus the quantity
one minus cosine squared theta. That simplifies
to two cosine squared theta minus one after
distributing the negative sign, and combining
like terms. So I have one double angle formula
for sine of two theta. And I have three versions
of the double angle formula for cosine of
two theta. Now let's use these formulas in
some examples. Let's find the cosine of two
theta. If we know that cosine theta is negative
one over root 10, and theta terminates in
quadrant three, we have a choice of three
formulas for cosine of two theta, I'm going
to choose the second one, because it only
involves cosine of theta on the right side.
And I already know my value for cosine theta.
Of course, I could use one of the other ones,
but then I'd have to work out the value of
sine theta. So plugging in, I get cosine of
two theta is twice negative one over root
n squared minus one, which simplifies to two
tenths minus one or negative eight tenths,
negative four fifths. Finally, let's solve
the equation two cosine x plus sine of 2x
equals zero. What makes this equation tricky
is that one of the trig functions has the
argument of just x, but the other trig function
has the argument of 2x. So I want to use my
double angle formula to rewrite sine of 2x.
I'll copy down the two cosine x, and now sine
of 2x is equal to two sine x cosine x. At
this point, I see a way to factor my equation,
I can factor out a two cosine x from both
of these two terms. That gives me one plus
sine x and the product there is equal to zero.
That means that either two cosine x is equal
to zero, or one plus sine x is equal to zero.
That simplifies two cosine x equals zero,
or sine x is negative one. Using my unit circle,
I see that cosine of x is zero at pi over
two, and three pi over two, while sine of
x is negative one at three pi over two, there's
some redundancy here, but my solution set
is going to be pi over two plus multiples
of two pi, and three pi over two plus multiples
of two pi. This video proved the double angle
formulas, sine of two theta is two sine theta
cosine theta. and cosine of two theta is cosine
squared theta minus sine squared theta. It
also proved two alternate versions of the
equation for cosine of two theta. This video
is about the half angle formulas for computing
cosine of theta over two and sine of theta
over two. Cosine of theta over two is either
a plus or minus the square root of one plus
cosine theta over two. To figure out whether
to use plus or minus, you need to know something
about what quadrant, the angle theta over
two is, if you're expecting cosine theta over
two to be negative, then you're gonna need
the negative sign, you're expecting this cosine
to be positive, then of course, you want the
positive sign since the square root of something
is always positive. Notice that this formula
always makes sense, because the inside of
the square root sign is always going to be
positive or zero. Since cosine theta can't
be any more negative than negative one, we
have a similar formula for sine of theta over
two, and that's plus or minus the square root
of one minus cosine theta over two. Notice
that the formulas for both cosine of A half
angle and sine of A half angle both have cosine
in them, they just differ by the positive
or negative side and the inside of the square
root. To see why these formulas hold, let's
recall the form In the last four double angles,
we know that cosine of 2x is equal to two
cosine squared x minus one, or we can write
cosine of 2x as one minus two, sine squared
of x. Of course, of course, we can also write
cosine of 2x as cosine squared x minus sine
squared x. But this one won't be relevant
to our discussion right now. So I'm going
to start with this first formula. And I'm
going to make the substitution theta equals
to x, that allows me to write cosine theta
is two cosine squared theta over two minus
one. Since if theta is 2x, then x is theta
over two. Now, I'm going to solve for cosine
of theta over two. So I'll add one to both
sides. Divide both sides by two
and take the square root of both sides. That
gives me that cosine of theta over two is
going to be plus or minus the square root
of cosine theta plus one over two, which is
the formula we're looking for. I can carry
a similar process out with the second formula.
I'll substitute theta for 2x, which means
that x is theta over two, that gives me cosine
theta is one minus two sine squared theta
over two. Now I'll solve for sine of theta
over two. I'll start by adding two sine squared
theta over two to both sides. Next, I'll subtract
cosine theta from both sides. Next, I'll divide
both sides by two. And finally, I'll take
the square root of both sides. That gives
me sine of theta over two is plus or minus
the square root of one minus cosine theta
over two, which is the formula I was looking
for. Now that we've got our formulas, and
know where they come from, let's use them
in an example. Let's suppose that sine theta
is four fifths, and theta is between pi over
two and pi. That means it's in the second
quadrant, we want to find the exact values
of cosine theta over two and sine theta over
two. Since theta is between pi over two and
pi, theta over two will be between pi over
four and pi over two. So theta over two is
somewhere in the first quadrant. That means
that cosine theta over two and sine theta
over two will both be positive. Let me write
down my half angle formulas. And I know I
can ignore the negative version and just use
the positive version. Now unfortunately, I'm
just given the value of sine theta and not
cosine theta, so I can't plug in directly,
first, I have to use this value to figure
out what cosine might be. I'll draw a right
triangle with angle theta. And since sine
of theta is four fifths, I'll decorate the
triangle with a four and a five on the hypothesis.
That means that this side length is going
to be five squared square root of five squared
minus four squared, which is the square root
of nine, which is three. That means that cosine
theta is going to be either plus or minus
three fifths because it's adjacent over hypotenuse.
Now since I'm in the angle, the second quadrant
for my angle theta, cosine is actually going
to be negative three fifths. Now I can plug
into my formulas, I get that cosine of theta
over two is going to be the square root of
one minus three fifths over two. That simplifies
to the square root of two fifths divided by
two, which is the square root of 1/5, or one
over the square root of five. Sine of theta
over two is the square root of one minus cosine
theta, so that's one minus negative three
fifths over two, that's the square root of
one plus three fifths, or eight fifths over
to the square root of four fifths or two over
the square root of five. In this video, we
found formulas for the cosine of A half angle,
and the sine of A half angle and use them
in an example. solving a right triangle means
finding the lengths of all the sides and the
measures of the angles given partial information.
In this example, we're given the length of
one side, and the measure of one angle. Plus
we know the measure of this right angle is
90 degrees, we need to find the measure of
the third angle labeled capital A, and the
length of the two sides labeled lowercase
b and lowercase C. To find the measure of
angle A, let's use the fact that the measures
of the three angles of a triangle add up to
180 degrees. So that means that 49 degrees
plus 90 degrees plus a is equal to 180 degrees.
So A is equal to 180 degrees minus 90 degrees
minus 49 degrees, which works out to 41 degrees.
To find the length of the side B, we have
a couple of possible options. We could use
the fact that tan of 49 degrees, which is
opposite over adjacent is B over 23. So b
is 23 times tan 49 degrees, which works out
to 26.46 units. Alternatively, we could use
the fact that tan of 41 degrees is 23 over
b since now if we're looking at the angle
here, 23 is our opposite and B is an adjacent,
that's a little bit harder to solve algebraically.
But we can write B tan 41 degrees equals 23,
which means that B is 23 divided by 1041 degrees
with a calculator that works out again to
26.46. The reason we want to use tan in this
problem and not say sine or cosine is because
tan of say 49 degrees relates the unknown
side that we're looking for B to the side
that we know the measure of if we had use
sine instead, we'll be saying that sine of
49 is B over C and we'd have two unknowns,
which would make it difficult to solve. Next,
to find the side length C, we can have a few
options, we could use a trig function again.
For example, we could use the cosine of 49
degrees, that's adjacent over hypotenuse,
which is 23 oversee. Solving for C, we get
that C is 23 over cosine 49. Which works out
to 35.06 units. Another option would be to
use the Pythagorean Theorem to find C. Since
we know 23 squared plus b squared equals c
squared. In other words, that's 23 squared
plus 26.46 squared equals c squared, which
means that C is the square root of that song,
which works out again to 35.06. To review
the ideas we used where the sum of the angles
is equal to 180 degrees. We used facts like
tangent of an angle being opposite over adjacent
and similar facts about sine and cosine. And
we use the Pythagorean Theorem. This allowed
us to find all the angles and side lengths
of the triangle knowing just the side length
of one side and the angle of one of the non
right angles to begin with. In this next example,
we don't know any of the angles except for
the right angle, but we know to have the side
lengths. To find the unknown angle theta,
we can use the fact that cosine theta is adjacent
overhype hotness, so that's 10 over 15. Cosine
is a good trig function to use here, because
this equation relates our unknown angle to
our two known sides. So we just have one unknown
in our equation to solve for. To solve for
theta, we just take the cosine inverse of
10/15 which is 0.8411 radians, or 48.19 degrees.
To find the measure of angle fee, we could
use the fact that sine of fee is 10 over 15
and take sine inverse of 10/15. But probably
a little easier just to use the fact that
these three angles do 180 degrees. That tells
us that fee plus 90 plus 48.19 is equal to
180 Which means that fee is 41.81. Finally,
we can find x, either using a trig function
or by using the Pythagorean Theorem. To find
it using a trig function, we could write down
something like tan of 48.19 degrees is x over
10. To find that using the Tyrion theorem,
we'd write down 10 squared plus x squared
equals 15 squared. I'll use the Pythagorean
theorem and find the x by doing the square
root of 15 squared minus 10 squared. That
gives me an answer of 11.18. Notice that we
use many of the same ideas as in the previous
problem. For example, the fact that the sum
of the angles is 180. The Pythagorean theorem
and the trig functions like tan, sine and
cosine, we also use the inverse trig functions
to get from an equation like this one to the
angle. This video showed how it's possible
to find the lengths of all the sides of a
right triangle. And then measures of all the
angles given partial information. For example,
the measure of one angle and one side or from
two sides. Recall that solving a triangle
means finding all the lengths of the sides
and all the measures of the angles from partial
information. The Law of Cosines is a tool
that can help us solve triangles that are
not necessarily right triangles. Recall that
the Pythagorean theorem says that for a right
triangle, like this one, the length of the
hypothesis is related to the lengths of the
sides by the formula c squared equals a squared
plus b squared. I like to think of the law
of cosines. As a generalization of the Pythagorean
Theorem, two triangles that are not necessarily
right triangles. loosely speaking, the Law
of Cosines says that c squared is equal to
a squared plus b squared plus a correction
factor where the correction factor depends
on the size of the angle, that's opposite
to side C. For this first triangle, on the
left, the angle that's opposite to side C
is exactly a right angle. So we know that
c squared is exactly equal to a squared plus
b squared. But in this next triangle, the
angle opposite decides C prime is a little
bit less than a right angle. So we expect
the side length C prime should be a little
bit shorter than the side length C in the
previous triangle that had the same side length
A and B for its legs. Therefore, C prime squared
should be less than a squared plus b squared,
or in other words, C prime squared should
equal a squared plus b squared minus a little
bit. In this third triangle, the angle opposite
C double prime is a little bigger than 90
degrees. So this side length C double prime
should be a little bit longer than the side
length C in the right triangle with the same
size legs. So C double prime squared should
be bigger than a squared plus b squared, we
can write this as C double prime squared is
equal to a squared plus b squared plus a little
bit. The Law of Cosines says precisely what
this little correction factor is. It says
that for any triangle with sides, a B and
C, and angle capital C, opposite side C, side
c squared is equal to a squared plus b squared
minus two A B, cosine angle C. Let's analyze
what happens with this equation when angle
C is equal to 90 degrees less than 90 degrees
and greater than 90 degrees. If angle C is
equal to 90 degrees, then cosine of angle
C is equal to zero. So we have that c squared
is equal to a squared plus b squared, the
ordinary Pythagorean Theorem. If on the other
hand, angle C is less than 90 degrees, then
from the unit circle, we know that cosine
of C is positive. So to a B, cosine C is a
positive number, and we'll be subtracting
a little bit from our A squared plus B squared,
just like we saw in the picture. Finally,
if angle C is bigger than 90 degrees, then
we can see from the unit circle that cosine
FC is negative. So to a B, cosine capital
C is going to be less than zero. And we're
going to be subtracting a negative number,
which means we're actually adding a little
bit, just like we saw in the third picture.
When labeling a triangle, the convention is
to use capital letters for the angles and
lowercase letters for the side lengths. And
to put side A opposite angle A, and so on.
When we wrote the law of cosines, on the previous
page, we wrote c squared equals a squared
plus b squared minus two A B, cosine angle
C. But it doesn't matter which side we call
a, which side we call B, and which side we
call C. All that matters is that this angle
is opposite to the side and between these
two sides. So we could have just as easily
written a squared is equal to b squared plus
c squared minus two B, C, cosine A. all we've
done is replace C with A, A with B, and B
with C and our labeling scheme. Or instead,
we could put the B squared on the left side
and right b squared equals a squared plus
c squared minus two a C, cosine B, we can
use whichever of these three forms is most
convenient for the problem at hand. Let's
use the law of cosines. To find all the side
lengths and angles in this triangle. By convention,
I'll call the side opposite to angle A little
a and the side opposite angle B, little B.
Notice that we know two side lengths and the
angle between them. So that's an S, a s, side
angle side triangle. If we write down the
law of cosines, with the unknown side, c squared
on the left side, then we have all the values
for the variables on the right side. So let's
plug them in. I'll use a calculator in degree
mode to find that c squared is equal to 44.44.
taking the square root, I get that c is equal
to 6.67. Next, I'll use the law of cosines.
To find the angle B, I'll need to use a version
of the Law of Cosines that has cosine be right
here. That's the version that has little b
squared on the left side and goes b squared
equals a squared plus c squared minus two
a C, cosine B. I can plug in values for all
my side lengths. And now I can solve for cosine
B. To do that, I'll subtract eight squared
and 6.67 squared from both sides. And now
I'll divide both sides by negative two times
eight times 6.67. using a calculator, this
gives me that cosine of B is equal to negative
0.1172. The negative value of cosine indicates
that my angle B must be greater than 90 degrees,
which agrees with the figure. Next, I can
take cosine inverse of both sides to get that
b is equal to cosine inverse negative 0.1172,
which works out to 96.73 degrees. The last
thing I need to do is solve for angle A, I
could use the Law of Cosines again, and work
out angle A just like I worked out angle B
here. But a simpler thing to do is to use
the fact that the sum of the three angles
equals 180 degrees. In other words, a plus
37 degrees plus 96.73 degrees equals 180 degrees.
So A is going to be 180 minus 37 minus 96.73,
which works out to 46.27 degrees. In the previous
example, we were given two sides, and the
angle between them. In this example, instead,
we're given three side lengths. So I'll call
this and s, s, s, side side side triangle,
we need to find all three angles. Although
there are a lot of computations involved,
the ideas are the same as in the previous
problem. Defined angle capital C, we need
the form of the Law of Cosines That has cosine
of C on the right side, and little C on the
left side. To find angle A, we need the form
of the Law of Cosines that has cosine A on
the right side and little a on the left side.
And to find angle B, we need the form of the
Law of Cosines that has cosine of B on the
right side, and little b squared on the left
side. For each of these three equations, I'll
plug in the side lengths. So for the cosines
and use inverse cosine to find my angles.
Notice that my three angles 60 degrees, 32
point 20 degrees, and 87.79 degrees add up
to just almost 180 degrees, the difference
is just around off error. In fact, I could
have saved myself some work by just finding
the measure of angle C, and the measure of
angle A, and then subtracting them from 180
degrees to get the measure of angle B. In
this video, we stated the law of cosines and
used it to solve some triangles. The Law of
Cosines can be thought of as the Pythagorean
Theorem, with the correction factor to account
for triangles that aren't right triangles.
Recall that solving a right triangle means
finding all the lengths of the sides and all
the measures of the angles from partial information.
The Law of Cosines is a tool that can help
us solve triangles that are not necessarily
right triangles. We call it the Pythagorean
theorem says that for a right triangle, like
this one, c squared is equal to a squared
plus b squared. I like to think of the law
of cosines. As a generalization of the Pythagorean
Theorem, two triangles that are not necessarily
right triangles. loosely speaking, the Law
of Cosines says that c squared is equal to
a squared plus b squared plus a correction
factor where the correction factor depends
on the size of the angle that's opposite sides
see, in this first triangle, on the left,
the angle opposite to side C is a right angle.
So we know that c squared is equal to exactly
a squared plus b squared. But on the next
triangle, the angle opposite to side C prime
is a little bit less than a right angle. So
this side, C prime should be a little shorter
than a squared plus b squared. All right,
C prime squared is equal to a squared plus
b squared minus a bit. In this third triangle,
says the angle opposite to side C double prime
is a little bit bigger than 90 degrees, this
side length should be a little bit bigger
than a squared plus b squared. So I'll write
it as a squared plus b squared plus a little
bit. The Law of Cosines says exactly what
this little correction factor is. It says
that for any triangle with sides, A, B and
C and angle capital C are opposite to side
C. C squared is equal to a squared plus b
squared minus two A B, cosine of angle C.
No notice that if the angle C is less than
90 degrees, cosine of C is going to be a positive
number. And so we'll be subtracting a positive
quantity, just like we saw in the picture
above. If however, angle C is bigger than
90 degrees, then cosine of c is negative.
So by subtracting to a B, cosine C, we're
actually adding a little bit, and we get a
longer side as in this picture. When labeling
a triangle, the convention is to use lowercase
letters for the side lengths and uppercase
letters for the angles, and to put angle A
opposite side A, and so on. When we wrote
the law of cosines, on the previous page,
we wrote c squared equals a squared plus b
squared minus two A B, cosine C. But it doesn't
matter which side we call a, which side we
call B, and which side the coffee. All that
matters is that this angle is opposite to
this side, and between these two sides, so
we could have just as easily written a squared
equals b squared plus c squared minus two
B, C code sine A or B squared equals a squared
plus c squared minus two a C, cosine B, we
can use whichever of these three forms is
most convenient for the problem at hand. Let's
use the law of cosines. To find the side length
the angles of this triangle, by convention,
I'm going to call the side opposite angle
B, side, little B, and the side opposite angle
A side, little a. Since we know two side lengths,
and the angle between them, we have all the
information on the right side of the law of
cosines. So I'll plug that in. And use a calculator
in degree mode to find that c squared equals
44.44. taking the square root, I get that
C equals 6.67. Next, I'll use the law of cosines.
To find the angle B, I need to use a version
of the law of cosines. That mentions cosine
of angle B here, so it'll need to mention
side length little B here. So that'll be the
form b squared. On the left, I'll get a squared
plus c squared minus two a C, cosine B. On
the right, I'll plug in values from my side
lengths. And now I can solve for cosine B
by subtracting eight squared, and 6.67 squared
from both sides. And now dividing both sides
by negative two times eight times 6.67. using
a calculator, this gives me that cosine of
B is equal to negative point 1172. The negative
value of cosine indicates that my angle B
must be greater than 90 degrees, which agrees
with a picture. Next, I can take cosine inverse
of both sides to get that b is equal to cosine
inverse of negative point 1172, which works
out to 96.73 degrees. The last thing I have
to do is solve for angle A, I could use the
Law of Cosines again, and work it out just
like I did here for angle B. But a simpler
method is to just use the fact that the sum
of the three angles is 180 degrees. So a must
be 180 degrees minus 37 degrees minus 96.73
degrees. This works out to 46.27 degrees.
In the previous example, we were given two
sides and the angle between them. In this
angle, were given instead, three side lengths,
and we need to find all three angles. Although
there are a lot of computations involved,
the ideas are the same as in the previous
problem. To find angle capital C, we need
the form of the law of cosines, that has cosine
of capital C on the right side, to find capital
B, we need to use the form of the Law of Cosines
that has cosine of B on the right side, and
little B on the left side. So it'll be b squared
equals a squared plus c squared minus two
a C cosine B. At the find angle A, we need
a little A squared on the left side. So that
will get cosine of angle A on the right side.
For each of these three equations, I'll plug
in the side lengths, solve for the cosine
of the angle and use inverse cosine to find
my angles. Notice that my three angles 60
degrees, 87.79 degrees, and 32 point 20 degrees
add up to almost exactly 180 degrees, it's
just a tiny bit off due to roundoff error.
In fact, I could have saved myself some work
by just finding the measure of angle C, and
the measure of angle B, for example, and then
subtracting their sum from 180 degrees to
get angle A. In this video, we stated the
law of cosines and used it to solve some triangles.
The Law of Cosines can be thought of as the
Pythagorean Theorem with an adjustment factor
to account for triangles that aren't right
triangles. The Law of Sines is a tool that
can be used to solve triangles that are not
necessarily right triangles. It's especially
useful when we know two angles and one side
and it can also be used in this situation
where we know two sides and an angle Let's
not between them. The Law of Sines says that
for a triangle with angles A, B and C, opposite
two sides, lowercase a, b, and c respectively.
The sine of angle A divided by the length
of side A is equal to the sine of B over B,
which is also equal to the sine of C over
C. Notice that we're taking the sine of the
three angles, and dividing by the three opposite
side lengths. Suppose we know that angle A
is 55 degrees, angle C is 67 degrees, and
Side B is 20 degrees, we want to solve the
triangle, that is find the length of the other
sides and the measure of the third angle.
Since we know two angles already, we can find
the third angle by subtracting from 180 degrees.
So angle B is 58 degrees. Now I can use the
Law of Sines to find my remaining side lengths.
To find side A, I'll use the fact that sine
of angle A over side length A is equal to
sine of angle B over side length B. Since
I already know three of these quantities,
angle A, angle B, and side length B, I can
plug in and solve for the unknown side length
a to solve or multiply both sides by a and
then multiply both sides by 20 over the sine
of 58 degrees. That gives me that a is equal
to 20 sine 55 oversized 58, which works out
to 19.32. Please pause the video and use the
same method to find side length See, this
time, we need to involve sign of C and sidelink
see in our equation. And we could use either
the B's or the A's since they're both known
for the other side. I'll plug in values as
I can and solve for C. C works out to 21.71.
In the previous example, we use the Law of
Sines to find the side lengths of a triangle,
because we already knew the angles. In this
next example, we're given some side lengths.
And we're going to need to solve for some
angles. This can be tricky, because when we
write down the law of sines and start solving
for an angle, we first solve for sine of the
angle. But there can be two plausible angles
that both have the same sign. For example,
if sine of the angle happens to be one half,
then the angle could be either 30 degrees,
or 150 degrees. In some cases, this can lead
to two possible triangles that both have the
conditions given When this happens, and there
are two possible solutions. I call this an
ambiguous case. With that warning, let's figure
out the details of this example. Plugging
in my given information into the law of signs,
I'll focus on this portion of the equation
where there's only one unknown to solve for.
First off, solve for sine of A, which is eight
times sine 40 degrees over seven, which works
out to 0.7346. From the unit circle, I can
see that there'll be two possible angles with
this sine one in the first quadrant and one
in the second quadrant. If I take sine inverse
of both sides of my equation, I get the solution
in the first quadrant, which is 47.27 degrees.
Since this angle right here is 47.27 degrees,
so is this angle here. And so the angle that
I want in the second quadrant I can get by
going 180 minus 47.27 degrees, which works
out to 132.731 of these possible angles. It's
an acute angle, the other one and obtuse angle,
but both are possible configurations are sketch
the possible triangles in both triangles,
side length A and B are the same and angle
B is the same But everything else is different.
We can continue to solve for the other angle
and side in each case. In the left side, I'll
call this case one, we can solve for angle
C, by taking 180 degrees minus angle B minus
angle A. That gives us an angle just over
90 degrees 92.73 degrees. Now we can use either
the Law of Sines or the law of cosines. To
find the final side length C, I'll use the
Law of Sines again. So I plug in the value
of angle C into this part of my equation,
and solve for C to get C equals sine 92.73
degrees times seven over sine 40 degrees,
which works out to 10.88. For the right hand
triangle, we can carry out the same steps
to get angle C. And now plug in to the Law
of Sines. To get side length to see, we finish
solving for the two possible triangles. With
these given side length, and angle. In this
video, we use the Law of Sines to solve a
triangle in two different situations. In the
first situation, we had two angles and the
side between them. So that's an A s, a triangle,
for angle, side angle. And that situation,
we ended up just using the law of science
to solve for side lengths, and there was no
ambiguity. In the second situation, we had
a triangle where we knew two side lengths
and an angle that was not between them. So
I'll call that s s A. And in that case, we
did find two possible triangles. That would
work. The SSA situation doesn't always give
two possible triangles. Sometimes when you
go through the two cases, and figure out all
the other angles and side lengths, you'll
get an impossible situation. And the angle,
for example, that's got to be negative. Because
the other two angles add up to more than 180
degrees by but you do have to be on the lookout
for two possible triangles when you're solving
a triangle with the SSA information given.
This video describes some of the features
of a parabola. Its vertex, focus and directrix.
I want to start by finding the equation of
all points that are equidistant the same distance
from a point zero p on the y axis, and the
horizontal line y equals negative P. I'm assuming
here that P is positive, for starters, certainly
the origin will be among those points as it
has a distance of P from the point and P from
the line. But the other points on the x axis
will be closer to the line than they are to
the point. So if I want the set of points
that are the same distance from the point
of the line, that's going to be a curve that
curved upwards, something like this. So for
example, a point out here will be the same
distance from the point as it is from the
line. So our intuition is suggesting that
this set of points should be the shape of
a parabola. Let's confirm this with some algebra.
If we take an arbitrary point, with coordinates
x, y, its distance from the point zero P is
given by the distance formula, x minus zero
squared plus y minus p squared. Its distance
from the line y equals negative P is just
given by its difference in Y coordinates.
So that's going to be y minus negative p or
y plus P. Let me set these two quantities
equal to each other. And simplify, I can square
both sides to get on the left x minus zero
squared with the same thing as x squared plus
y minus p squared equals y plus p squared.
Now I'll distribute out, that gives me x squared
plus y squared minus two p y plus p squared
equals y squared plus two p y plus p squared.
The P squares cancel out as do the Y squared,
and I'm left with x squared equals four p
y after move In this negative two p y to the
other side, I could also write this as y equals
one over four p x squared. And you might recognize
this as the standard parabola y equals x squared,
transformed by vertically stretched it stretching
or shrinking it by this factor of whenever
for pee. You might recall that this lowest
point of the parabola is called the vertex.
This point here is called its focus. And the
line here is called the directrix. Notice
that the number of P in this equation represents
the distance between the vertex and the focus,
and also represents the distance between the
vertex and the directrix line. For this reason,
if you're interested in the focus and the
vertex, this form of the equation might be
more useful than the equivalent form something
like y equals A x squared, where the that
distance P is more hidden. Now, so far, we've
just considered the case when a p is greater
than zero. Let's look for a moment at what
happens when p is less than zero, then when
we draw the point zero, P is going to be below
the x axis. And the directrix y equals negative
P is going to be above the x axis because
we're taking the negative of a negative number
makes it a positive y value. Our parabola
will also be upside down. All the algebra
works out the same is just in our equation,
this coefficient of y will now be a negative
number instead of a positive one. Or if we
write it in this other form, which might be
more familiar, our coefficient of x squared
will be negative instead of positive, which
signifies that the parabola is pointing down.
Since P is now a negative number, if we want
to talk about distances, we should write absolute
value of p instead of P. Next, let's turn
things sideways by looking at the equation
for all points equidistant from a point P
zero. on the x axis. Here, we're assuming
For starters, that P is bigger than zero,
and a vertical line at x equals negative P.
Our intuition suggests that this should be
a parabola pointing sideways. And we can work
out the same algebra steps to get an equation
for it. Starting with an arbitrary point,
x y, the distance from the point P zero is
going to be given by x minus p squared plus
y minus zero squared, the distance from the
line x equals negative P is going to be given
by the difference in x coordinates. So that's
going to be x minus negative p, or just x
plus P. I'll set these two distances equal
to each other, square both sides like before,
and simplify. This gives me the equation y
squared equals four p x, which I could also
rewrite as x equals one over four p y squared
or x equals A y squared, where my a corresponds
to my one over four P. Once again, if p is
negative, then I probably pointing the opposite
direction, but my equation will still be the
same, it'll just have a negative coefficient
of x instead of a positive one. The negative
number of being hidden inside this variable
P. As before, the absolute value of p gives
me the distance between the vertex and the
focus, and also gives me the distance between
the vertex and the directrix. Now let's find
the equation of a parabola with a vertex at
some arbitrary point h k instead of the origin,
assuming that the parabola opens up or down.
If the parabola had its vertex at the origin,
we know it would be given by the equation
x squared equals four p y, or I could rewrite
that as y equals one over four p x squared.
So this parabola should just be shifted to
the right by H and up by K. From transformations
of functions. We know we can accomplish this
by sticking a x minus h on the inside and
putting a plus k on the outside. In other
words, we have y minus k equals one over four
P times x minus h squared. Or we can write
this as x minus h squared equals four P times
y minus k. So this is the original All with
a vertex at the origin, and here is the transformed
by shifting right and up to have a vertex
at h k, notice that the equations are exactly
the same. It's just you stuck in a minus h
and a minus k near the X and near the y, this
transform parabola will have its focus, a
distance of P up from the vertex. So that's
going to be the point h, k plus p, that's
going to have as directrix at a distance p
down from the vertex. So that's going to be
the line y equals k minus P. Everything's
the same for this other parabola pointing
downwards, we just have P is negative in that
case, the same story holds for the parabola
is pointing right and left, the original equation,
y squared equals four p x gets transformed
when we shift the parabola over into y minus
k squared equals four p x minus h. This time,
the vertex is a distance p to the left or
right of my vertex. So here it would be h
plus p, k. And the directrix would be shifted
over by P also from the vertex. So this would
be the vertical line x equals h minus P. It
works the same way, when the parabola is opening,
left instead of right, it's just in this case,
P is negative. Let's use this information
to find the equation of a parabola with vertex
at two, four, and focus at negative one, four.
I'll start with a quick sketch, which will
help me see how the parabola is lined up.
So here's the vertex at two, four. And the
focus is at negative one, four. So here's
the focus here. Now says the problem always
has its focus, that means that this problem
must be pointing left and looks something
like this. The directrix is going to be on
the other side of the parabola, the same distance
as the distance between the vertex and the
focus. Since this distance is a distance of
three to minus negative one is three, the
directrix must be three units over here to
the right, and so that would be the line x
equals five. Since my problems open to the
left, I know I need to use the form of the
equation y minus k squared equals four p x
minus h, where h k is the vertex, so that's
two four, I also know that P is going to be
negative. And since the absolute value of
p represents the distance between the vertex
and the focus, I know that P must be negative
three. So filling on all these numbers, I
get y minus four squared equals four times
negative three times x minus two. I'll simplify
that to y minus four squared equals negative
12x minus two. In this video, we looked at
special forms of the equation for a parabola,
the forms y minus k squared equals four p
x minus h, and x minus h squared equals four
p y minus k. In these equations, h k represents
the vertex and PS absolute value gives the
distance between the vertex and the focus
and between the vertex and the directrix.
parabolas in this form, are opening right
if p is bigger than zero, and left if p is
less than zero, and parabolas in this form,
are opening up if p is bigger than zero, and
down if p is less than zero. This video is
about ellipses. Recall that a circle can be
defined as a set of points whose distance
from a fixed point is a constant. And he lips
can be defined as a set of points, such that
the sum of the distances from two fixed points
is a constant. The two fixed points are called
focuses or foe sigh The sum of the distances
to the to fo Sai is the total length of the
string, which is held constant as I draw the
ellipse. Let's examine the features of an
ellipse in more detail. In these pictures,
the two black dots are the focuses or fo sigh.
The red line segment that cuts through the
middle of the ellipse in the long direction
and passes through this low sigh, it's called
the major axis. The line segment that cuts
through the middle of the ellipse in the shorter
direction is called the minor axis. And the
two points at the tips of the ellipse where
the major axis actually touches the ellipse
are called the vertices. And ellipse could
be elongated in any direction, but will only
consider ellipses that are elongated either
in the horizontal direction, or the vertical
direction. Let's find the equation of an ellipse
whose fo cy are at negative c zero, and c
zero, and whose vertices are at negative a
zero and a zero. This will be an ellipse that's
elongated in the horizontal direction. For
any point x, y on the ellipse, the sum of
the distance from x y to the first focus,
plus its distance to the second focus has
to be some constant. And in fact, it turns
out that constant has to equal to a, I'll
show you why. If you look at this point right
here on the far right tip of the ellipse,
its distance from the first focus is going
to be to C plus a minus C. And as distance
from the second focus is just going to be
a minus say, if you add up c plus c plus a
minus c plus a minus C, you get exactly to
a. So let me write out my formulas for distances,
the distance from a point x y to the first
focus, the point negative c zero is going
to be the square root of x minus negative
c squared plus y minus zero squared. And the
distance from x y to the second focus, the
point c zero is going to be the square root
of x minus c squared plus y minus zero squared.
That Psalm needs to add up to two a, after
a fair amount of algebra, this simplifies
the expression a squared minus c squared x
squared plus a squared y squared equals a
squared times a squared minus c squared. If
we let b squared equals a squared minus c
squared, then we can rewrite this as b squared
x squared plus a squared y squared equals
a squared b squared, and dividing both sides
by a squared b squared, this gives us the
form of the equation for the ellipse x squared
over a squared plus y squared over b squared
equals one. Since we got b squared as a squared
minus c squared, it follows that b is less
than a. In fact, B is half the length of the
minor axis. In other words, this point right
here is the point zero, B, and this point
is the point zero negative B. To see why this
is true, let's draw these two right triangles.
The sum of the side lengths that I've drawn
has to be the total length of the string.
So that equals to a, which means each of these
side lengths must be a. Now the base of this
triangle is C. So by the Pythagorean Theorem,
this height squared must be a squared minus
c squared. Since b squared is defined as a
squared minus c squared, this height must
be B. To summarize, for a number a bigger
than B, the equation x squared over a squared
plus y squared over b squared equals one represents
any lips. That's elongated in the horizontal
direction, whose major axis terminates in
the points minus a zero, and a zero, and whose
minor access terminates in the points zero
B, and zero minus b. It's fo cy are at the
points negative c zero, and c zero. And the
relationship between a B and C is that b squared
is a squared minus c squared equivalently.
If we add c squared to both sides, and subtract
b squared from both sides, we can write See
squared equals a squared minus b squared.
The way I remember this is that the biggest
of the three numbers A, B, and C is definitely
going to be a, since a is half the length
of the major axis, which is bigger than half
the length of the minor axis, and definitely
bigger than the length between the origin
and one of the focuses. Since a is the biggest,
and we have a Pythagorean Theorem relationship
between a, b and c, the equation must be b
squared plus c squared equals a squared, which
can be rearranged to either of these two equations.
Now what happens instead, if we have a bigger
than B still, but this time, we're dividing
y squared by the bigger number squared, and
x squared by the smaller number squared? Well,
this basically reverses the roles of x and
y in my equation. And so we end up with the
major axis on the y axis stretching between
the points, zero a, and zero negative a, whereas
the minor axis is going to be along the x
axis going in between negative b zero, and
B zero, and the first side are going to be
here on the y axis again. So in this case,
my lives is elongated in the vertical direction.
Our previous ellipses were centered at the
origin. What if the ellipse is centered instead
of an arbitrary point, HK, well, then we need
to shift everything over by h in the horizontal
direction, and K in the vertical direction.
So instead of the equation, x squared over
a squared plus y squared over b squared equals
one, we're gonna have to have x minus h squared
over a squared plus y minus k squared over
b squared equals one, where A is bigger than
B, that's for an ellipse elongated in the
horizontal direction. If we want an ellipse
elongated in the vertical direction, we'll
still take a bigger than B, but we'll reverse
the roles of x and y. So this becomes x squared
over b squared plus y squared over a squared
equals one for the center at the origin. And
to shifted over, we get x minus h squared
over b squared plus y minus k squared over
a squared equals one. I'll draw some pictures
below. With some thought we can label key
points. For example, this vertex must be shifted
over by an amount a, since a is half the length
of the major axis. So it'll have coordinates
H plus a, k was this vertex will be h minus
A k. This point up here should be h, k plus
b, and this one, h k minus b, the fo cy are
it, H plus c, k, and H minus C. Okay. We can
label the points on the ellipse that's elongated
vertically. Similarly, let's write the equation
of the ellipse drawn below, and then we'll
find it so cy, its major axis is in the vertical
direction, right here. Its top vertex is at
the point four, three, as bottom vertex is
at the point for negative nine. Its center
is halfway between its two vertices, which
is right here, at the point four, negative
three. Finally, I can read off the points
at the end of the minor axis. So this one
is at nine, negative three, and this one is
at negative one, negative three. Since my
lips is elongated vertically, I know I have
an equation of the form x minus h squared
over b squared plus y minus k squared over
a squared equals one with a bigger than be
my center is my point h k. And that's equal
to four negative three, a is half the length
of the major axis. So that's the vertical
distance between this point and this point,
I can just take the difference of Y coordinates
and see that a is equal to six. B is half
the length of a minor axis. So looking at
the difference in x coordinates of these two
points, I see that b is equal to five. Throwing
that all into my equation, I get that x minus
four squared over five squared plus y plus
three squared over six squared equals one,
the fo cy are going to be somewhere along
the major axis somewhere above and below the
center. To figure out how far they are, I
need to use the fact that c squared is equal
to a squared minus b squared. So in this case,
c squared is six squared minus five squared,
which is 11. Which means that C is the square
root of 11, which is a little bit bigger than
three So, the two first sigh, our distance
of squared of 11, above and below the center,
and so they'll have coordinates of four, negative
three plus a squared of 11 and four, negative
three minus the square root of 11. This video
detailed the anatomy of ellipse, including
its major axis, its minor axis, its vertices,
and its fossa. This video is about hyperbolas.
You might recall that any lips is the set
of points x y, such that the sum of the distances
between x y and two fixed points called the
fo cy is a constant. Well, I hyperbola is
a set of points x y, such that the difference
of the distances between x y and each of two
fixed points, called the first side is a constant.
In this picture on the left, the two blue
lines are the two branches of the hyperbola.
The two red points are the focuses or foe
side. So, for a point x, y on the hyperbola.
If I look at the distance from x, y to one
focus, and the distance from x, y to the other
focus, the difference of those two distances
will be the same no matter which point x y
on the hyperbola that I choose. If I draw
a line between the two fourths I, that line
is called the transverse axis. In this left
picture, we have a vertical transverse axis.
And the hyperbola itself reminds me of a person
lying down horizontally. Now in the right
picture, our transverse axis between the two
fo psi is horizontal. And the blue hyperbola
itself kind of reminds me of a person standing
up vertically. It's possible for a hyperbola
to be oriented other ways besides horizontally
and vertically, but will only consider horizontal
and vertical orientations in this video. If
you look at where the transverse axis intersects
the blue branches of the hyperbola, you'll
find these two points. those points are called
the vertices. Notice that the vertices are
the two points on the two branches that are
closest to one another. The point halfway
between the two vertices, it's also halfway
between the two foes side is called the center
of the hyperbola. The two black dotted lines
that I've drawn that form an X are not actually
part of the hyperbola. They're called the
asymptotes. And you can think of them as guidelines
for drawing the hyperbola. Because the hyperbola
gets closer and closer to these asymptotes,
but doesn't cross them. We'll talk more about
the asymptotes later. Let's find the equation
of a hyperbola with both sides at negative
c zero, and c zero, and vertices at negative
a zero and a zero. This hyperbola will have
at center at the origin. From the distance
definition of hyperbola. We know that if we
have a point x, y on the hyperbola, then if
we take the distance from that point to the
first focus, and the distance to the second
focus and subtract them, we should get a constant.
We're always taking the positive difference
here. So if we're on the right branch, we'll
take the distance to the left focus minus
the shorter distance to the right focus. And
if we happen to be on the left branch, then
we would take the longer distance to the right
focus minus the shorter distance, the left
focus, when we do the differences that way,
we should always get the same number. And
in fact, that difference should equal to A
I'll show you why. The reason is, if I take
my point to be this vertex here, then its
distance to this focus is exactly c minus
A because C is bigger than a. And this distance
to that focus is going to be well let's see,
this is a, this is a and this is c minus a.
So that different distance will be a plus
a plus c minus a. Now I'm going to do the
difference, A plus A plus c minus a minus
c minus a. That simplifies to A plus c minus
c plus a, which is two a. Now I'll focus on
a point on the right branch, I'll actually
write a formula for its distance to this point.
That's the distance formula, it's going to
be x minus negative c squared plus y minus
zero squared. That's the longer difference
distance. Now I subtract the shorter distance,
which is the distance to this focus. And they're
the distance formula gives me x minus c squared
plus y minus zero squared. That should always
equal to A for any point on that right branch.
I'll clean up the inside of the square roots
a little bit. After that a chunk of algebra,
which I won't do here allows you to simplify
this equation to see squared minus a squared
times x squared minus a squared y squared
equals a squared times c squared minus a squared.
Since this expression, c squared minus a squared
is appearing a couple times here, I'm going
to give it a new name, I'm going to let b
squared b c squared minus a squared. Now I
can rewrite my equation as b squared x squared
minus a squared y squared equals a squared
b squared. And dividing both sides by a squared
b squared, you'll have the equation x squared
over a squared minus y squared over b squared
equals one. In this equation, notice that
a represents the distance from the center
to a vertex. The quantity C is not directly
in this equation, but it's related to a and
b by this equation, which can also be rewritten
as c squared equals a squared plus b squared.
Or if you prefer, a squared equals c squared
minus b squared. I remember this one. And
remember that C, which is the distance from
the center to the focus is the largest of
the three quantities A, B, and C. So you might
be wondering, Well, what is B represent? Well,
I'm going to draw a box, whose center is at
the center of my parabola that stretches out
in a from either direction left, right, and
stretches up by B in either direction, up
and down. It turns out that the corners of
such a box will be exactly on these two asymptote
lines. In other words, the slope of this asymptote,
its rise over its run is b over a. And for
this asymptote that's slipping downwards.
Its rise over it's Ron is negative b over
a. So I can actually write the equations of
the asymptotes. For this hyperbola, centered
at the origin as y equals B over A x and y
equals negative B over A x. We did all this
work for a standing up hyperbola with its
transverse axis oriented horizontally. Let
me rearrange things. And we'll see what changes
if a hyperbola is oriented the other way.
In this case, where we have a vertical transverse
axis, the roles of x and y are completely
switched. So our equation, which we could
derive the same way, becomes y squared over
a squared minus x squared over b squared equals
one, we still have the same formulas c squared
equals a squared plus b squared. And the two
related formulas b squared equals c squared
minus a squared, and a squared equals c squared
minus b squared. A is still the distance from
the center to the vertex. And c still represents
the distance from the center to a focus. Now
our box will extend up and down by a units
and left and right by b units. So this time,
the slope of the asymptote, the rise over
the run is going to be a over b for the line
that sloped up and negative a Overby for the
line that sloped down. This means our asymptotes,
which go through the center at the origin
will be given by the equations y equals a
over b x and y equals negative a over bx.
I want to point out that in this notation,
a is going with x in one form of the equation
and y and the other form of the equation,
but it always goes with the positive term,
the term that's added and subtracted, whereas
B goes with the negative term, the term that
subtracted which term is positive there, the
x squared or the Y squared determines the
orientation of the hyperbola this way or that
way. So far, we've been considering only hyperbola
Due to the origin, and we had these two equations
for them, if we sent her as an arbitrary point,
HK, instead, we just subtract h from the x
term and subtract k from the y term. The graphs
are shifted over by age and up by K. And to
get to the vertices, we just start at the
center, and go left and right, by a, or up
and down by a depending on which way the hyperbola
is oriented. So the vertices here are at h
plus a K, and H minus A k. Whereas over here,
the vertices are at h, k plus a and h, k minus
a. To get to the focuses, we have to go over
by C, or up and down by c, where c squared
equals a squared plus b squared. Finally,
the asymptotes still have the same slopes
as before. But this time, they have to go
through the center, which is at h k instead
of 00. Their equations are going to be given
by y minus k equals B over A x minus h. And
y minus k is negative B over A x minus h,
or with the other orientation, the analogous
thing y minus k equals a over b x minus h,
and y minus k equals A over B, negative a
over b, x minus h. We've done all the abstract
theory, let's do one example with numbers.
If we're given this hyperbola, we can read
off its center as six, negative three. Since
the x term is positive, I'm gonna let A be
the square root of four, and B will be the
square root of 25. Since the x term is positive,
and the y term is negative, the hyperbola
is going to be oriented standing up like this.
With a horizontal transverse axis, the distance
from the center to each vertex is given by
the number A, which is two. So the left vertex
will have coordinates for negative three,
and the right vertex will have coordinates
eight, negative three. To find the full side,
I need to figure out c squared, which is a
squared plus b squared, or four plus 2529.
So C is the square root of 29. I'll sketch
ballpark position of my first eye here, and
the coordinates are going to be at let's see,
the center is six, so six minus square 29,
same y coordinate of negative three, and the
six plus squared of 29 negative three. Finally,
the asymptotes will form an X going through
the center with slope given by B over A, which
is five has and negative b over a negative
five halves. The equations for those lines
will be y plus three, coming from the center
equals five halves x minus six, and y plus
three equals negative five halves x minus
six. This gives a decent rough sketch of the
hyperbola. If I want to be a little more accurate,
I could also plot some points by plugging
in values of x and solving for y or vice versa.
In this video, we gave two equations for hyperbolas.
Which one you use depends on how the hyperbola
is oriented. A has to do with the distance
between the center and the vertex, the number
c, which can be figured out from the equation
c squared equals a squared plus b squared,
is going to represent the distance from the
center to the focus. And B and A together
help determine the slope of the asymptotes.
This video introduces the idea of polar coordinates.
Polar Coordinates give an alternative way
of describing the location of points on the
plane. Instead of describing a point in terms
of its x and y coordinates, those are the
Cartesian coordinates of the point. When using
polar coordinates, we instead describe the
point in terms of radius r, and an angle theta.
r is the distance of the point from the origin
and theta is the angle that radius line makes
with the positive x axis. Let's plot these
points given in polar coordinates. So the
eight here is the value of the radius, and
the negative two thirds pi is the value of
the angle theta. The negative angle means
that I need to go clockwise from the positive
x axis, instead of counterclockwise, like
I normally would for a positive angle. So
here, a negative two thirds pi means that
I need to go to this line right here. And
the eight of for the radius means I need to
go eight lines out from the origin. So my
point should be around right here. The next
point has a radius of five and an angle of
three pi. The angle of positive three pi means
that I go counterclockwise starting at the
positive x axis, here, I've gone around by
two pi. And here, I've got an extra pi to
make three pi. Now the radius of five means
I need to go five units out from the origin.
So that puts me about right here. Notice that
I could have also labeled this point with
the polar coordinates of five Pi, there's
more than one way to assign polar coordinates
to a point. The next point has an angle of
pi over four, and a radius of negative 12.
The negative radius means that I need to jump
to the other side of the circle before I plot
the point. In other words, instead of plotting
the point at an angle of pi over four and
a radius of 12, which would be about right
here, I go to the opposite side of the circle,
and plotted at the same distance from the
origin, but 180 degrees or pi radians around
the circle over here. Now I could have also
labeled this point using a positive radius
of 12. And using an angle of pi over four
plus pi, or five pi over four. And in general,
a point with polar coordinates of negative
r theta means the same point as the point
with polar coordinates r, theta plus pi, adding
pi just makes us jump around to the opposite
side of the circle. To convert between polar
and Cartesian coordinates, it's handy to use
the following equations. First, x is equal
to r cosine theta, y is equal to r sine theta
r squared is equal to x squared plus y squared,
which means that R is plus or minus the square
root of x squared plus y squared. And tangent
theta is equal to y divided by x. Let's see
where these equations come from. If we draw
a point with coordinates, x, y, and draw lines
to make a right triangle, the height of that
triangle is y, the length of the base is x.
And the high partners has length r, theta
is the measure of this interior angle. From
trig, we know that cosine theta is equal to
adjacent over high partners. So that's x over
r, which means that x is equal to r cosine
theta. Similarly, sine theta is opposite over
hypotenuse, that's y over r, which means that
y is equal to r sine theta. That gives us
the first two equations. The Pythagorean Theorem
tells us that x squared plus y squared is
equal to r squared. And that gives us the
third equation. Finally, tangent theta is
opposite over adjacent. So that's y over x,
which is the fourth equation. To convert five,
negative pi over six from polar to Cartesian
coordinates, we just use the fact that x equals
r cosine theta, and y equals r sine theta.
So in this case, x is equal to five times
cosine of negative pi over six, that's five
times square root of three over two, and y
is equal to five sine negative pi over six.
So that's equal to negative five halves to
convert negative one, negative one From Cartesian
to polar coordinates, we know that negative
one and negative one are x and y values. So
we need to use the fact that r squared is
x squared plus y squared, that is r squared
is negative one squared plus negative one
squared are two. Also, tangent theta is y
over x, so that's negative one over negative
one, or one. Now there's several values of
r and theta that satisfy these equations are
could be squared of two, or negative the square
root of two, and theta could be Pi over four,
or five pi over four. Or we could add multiples
of two pi to either of these answers. But
not all combinations of r and theta, get us
to the right point. The point with Cartesian
coordinates negative one negative one lies
in the third quadrant. But if we use a theta
value of say, pi over four and an R value
of square root of two, that would get us to
the first quadrant. So instead, we need to
use the polar coordinates of square root of
two and five pi over four. Or if we prefer,
negative square root of two, and pi over four.
We could also add any multiple of two pi to
either of these values of theta, and get yet
another way of representing the point and
polar coordinates. This video talked about
polar coordinates, and converting between
Cartesian coordinates and polar coordinates,
using some familiar equations from trig. This
video introduces the idea of parametric equations,
instead of describing a curve as y equals
f of x, we can describe the x coordinates
and y coordinates separately in terms of a
third variable t, usually thought of as time.
so we can write x as a function of t, and
y as a separate function of t. This is especially
useful as a way to describe curves that don't
satisfy the vertical line test, and therefore
can't be described traditionally as functions
of y in terms of x. A Cartesian equation for
a curve is an equation in terms of x and y
only. parametric equations for a curve give
both x and y as functions of a third variable,
usually T. The third variable is called the
parameter. That's our first example, let's
graph the parametric equations given here
on an x y coordinate axis. Well, we'll do
this by finding x and y coordinates that correspond
to the same value of t. For example, when
t is negative two, you can calculate that
x by plugging in negative two for t gives
you five and why, when you plug in negative
two for t gives you eight. Please pause the
video for a moment and fill in some additional
values of x and y. For some additional values
of t. Your chart should look like this. And
when we plot the XY pairs and connect the
dots, we get something like this. It says
this point over here corresponds to a T value
of negative two. And this point over here
corresponds to the t value of two. So if we
think of t as time, we're traversing the curve
in this direction. To find a Cartesian equation
for this curve, we need to eliminate the variable
t from these equations. One way to do this
is to solve for t and one equation, say the
first equation. So two t is equal to one minus
x, which means that t is one half minus x
over two, then we can plug that expression
for t into the second equation and get y equals
one half minus x over two squared plus four,
which simplifies to the quadratic equation,
y equals 1/4 X squared minus one half x plus
17 fourths. Let's try some more examples.
A table of values for the first example helps
us draw the familiar graph of a circle of
radius one. This should come as no surprise
since the equations x equals cosine t and
y equals sine t are familiar from trig as
a way of describing the x&y coordinates of
a point on the unit circle. Notice that when
t equals zero, our curve lies on the positive
x axis. And as t increases from zero to two
pi, we traverse the curve once in the counterclockwise
direction. A Cartesian equation for this unit
circle is given by the equation x squared
plus y squared equals one. This follows from
the trig identity cosine squared t plus sine
squared t equals one by substituting in X
for cosine t, and y for sine t. Please pause
the video for a moment to graph the second
curve and rewrite it as a Cartesian equation.
The table of values should help you see that
the graph is again a unit circle. But this
time, as t increases from zero to two pi,
we actually traverse the circle twice in the
clockwise direction, I'll draw this with a
double arrow going clockwise. The Cartesian
equation for this graph is still x squared
plus y squared equals one. And so we found
two different parameterizations. For the same
graph on the X Y axis. Let's take a look at
the third equation. There's no interval value
specified for t here. So let's just assume
that t can be any real number. Now as T ranges
from negative infinity to infinity, our Y
values, which are given by cosine t, oscillate
between one and negative one. Our x values
are always the square of our Y values. So
the graph of this curve has to lie on the
graph of x equals y squared, which is a sideways
parabola. But a parametrically defined curve
doesn't cover this whole parabola. Remember
that y is given by cosine of t. So y can only
range between negative one and one. And so
we're only getting the portion of the parabola
that I shade in here. As t varies from say,
zero to pi, I traverse this parabola one time.
And then as t goes from pi to two pi, I go
back again in the other direction. And as
T continues to increase, I traverse this parabola
infinitely many times. The Cartesian equation
for this curve is the equation x equals y
squared with the restriction that y is between
negative one and one. We've seen several examples
where we went from parametric equations to
Cartesian equations. Now let's start with
a Cartesian equation and rewrite it as a parametric
equation. In this example, y is already given
as a function of x. So an easy way to parameterize.
This curve is to just let x equal t. And then
y is equal to the square root of t squared
minus t, substituting in T for x, the domain
restriction in terms of x just translates
into a restriction in terms of t. I call this
the copycat parameterization. Since we've
successfully introduced the new variable t,
but T just copies, whatever x does. In the
second example, we could try setting x equal
to t, then we get 25 t squared plus 36. Y
squared is equal to 900. and solving for y,
we'd have y squared equals 900 minus 25 t
squared over 36. So why is plus or minus the
square root of this quantity? This is a very
awkward looking expression. In fact, why is
that even a function of t here because of
the plus and minus signs. So let's look for
a better way to parameterize this curve. Because
of the x squared and the y squared, this equation
is a good candidate for parameterizing using
sine and cosine. In fact, if we divide both
sides of the equation by 900, we get 25x squared
over 900 plus 36. Y squared over 900 is equal
to one, which simplifies to x squared over
36 plus y squared over 25 is equal to one.
If I rewrite this as x over six squared plus
y or five squared equals one, then I can set
x over six equal to cosine of t, and y over
five equal to sine of t. And I can see that
for any value of t, x over six and y over
five will satisfy this equation, simply because
cosine squared plus sine squared equals one.
This gives me the parameterization x equals
six cosine of t, y equals five sine of t,
which is a handy way to describe any lips.
As a final example, let's describe a general
circle of radius r, and center HK. For any
point, x, y on the circle, we know that the
distance from that point x y to the center
of the circle is equal to r. So using the
distance formula, we know that the square
root of x minus h squared plus y minus k squared
has to equal our squaring both sides, this
gives us the equation for the circle in Cartesian
coordinates. So for example, if our circle
has radius five, and has Center at the point,
negative 317, then its equation would be x
minus negative three, that's x plus three
squared plus y minus 17 squared is equal to
25. One way to find the equation of a general
circle in parametric equations, is to start
with the unit circle and work our way up.
We know that the unit circle with radius one
centered at the origin is given by the equation
x equals cosine t, and y equals sine t. If
we want a circle of radius r centered around
the origin instead, then we need to expand
everything by a factor of R. So we multiply
our x and y coordinates by R. If we now want
the center to be at HK instead of at the origin,
then we need to add h to our x coordinates
and add K to all our Y coordinates. This gives
us the general equation for a circle in parametric
equations. to match the Cartesian equation
above, we can write our same example circle
and parametric equations as x equals five
cosine t minus three, y equals five sine t
plus 17. In this video, we translated back
and forth in between Cartesian equations and
parametric equations with a special emphasis
on the equations for circles. This video is
about the difference quotient, and the average
rate of change. These are topics that are
related to the concept of derivative and calculus.
For function y equals f of x, like the function
whose graph right here, a secant line is a
line that stretches between two points on
the graph of the function. I'm going to label
this x value as a and this x value as B. So
this point here on the graph is going to have
an x value of a and a y value given by f of
a, the second point will have x value B and
Y value f of b. Now the average rate of change
for a function on the interval from a to b
can be defined as the slope of the secant
line between the two points A F of A and B
f P. in symbols, that slope m is the rise
over the run, or the change in y over the
change in x, which is the difference in Y
coordinates f of b minus F of A over the difference
in x coordinates b minus a. So this is the
average rate of change. To put this in context,
if for example, f of x represents the height
of a tree. And x represents time in years,
then f of b minus f of a represents a difference
in height, or the amount the tree grows. And
B minus A represents a difference in in years,
so a time period. So this average rate of
change is the amount the tree grows in a certain
time period. For example, if it grows 10 inches
in two years, that would be 10 inches per
two years, or five inches per year would be
its average rate of change its average rate
of growth, let's compute the average rate
of change for the function f of x equals square
root of x on the interval from one to four.
So the average rate of change is f of four
minus f of one over four minus one, well,
f of four is the square root of four of one's
a square root of one. So that's going to be
two minus one over three or 1/3. Instead of
calling these two locations on the x axis,
a and b, this time, I'm going to call the
first location, just x and the second location,
x plus h. The idea is that h represents the
horizontal distance between these two locations
on the x axis. In this notation, if I want
to label this point on the graph of y equals
f of x, it'll have an x coordinate of x and
a y coordinate of f of x. The second point
will have an x coordinate of x plus h, and
a y coordinate of f of x plus h. a difference
quotient is simply the average rate of change
using this x x plus h notation. So a different
version represents the average rate of change
of a function, f of x on the interval from
x to x plus h. Equivalent way, the difference
quotient represents the slope of the secant
line for the graph of y equals f of x between
the points with coordinates x, f of x, and
x plus h, f of x plus h. Let's work out a
formula for the difference quotient. Remember
that the formula for the average rate of change
could be written as f of b minus F of A over
B minus A, where a and b are the two locations
on the x axis. But now I'm calling instead
of a I'm using x instead of B, I'm using x
plus h. So I can rewrite this average rate
of change as f of x plus h minus f of x over
x plus h minus x. That simplifies a little
bit on the denominator. Because x plus h minus
x, I can cancel the Xs, and I get the difference
quotient formula f of x plus h minus f of
x over h. The quantity h on this nominator
It looks like a single entity, but it still
represents a difference in x values. Let's
find and simplify the difference quotient
for this function given first, or write down
the general formula for the difference quotient.
That's f of x plus h minus f of x over h.
I'm going to compute f of x plus h first,
I do this by shoving in x plus h, everywhere
I see an x in the formula for the function,
that's going to give me two times x plus h
squared minus x plus h plus three. Notice
how I use parentheses here. That's important
because I need to make sure I shove in the
entire x plus h for x. So the entire x plus
h needs to be subtracted, not just the x part,
so the parentheses are mandatory. Similarly,
the parentheses here signal that the entire
x plus h is squared as it needs to be. I mean
going to go ahead and simplify a bit right
now. I can multiply out the x plus h squared,
I can go ahead and distribute the negative
sign. So if I multiply out, I'm gonna get
X squared plus X h plus h x plus h squared.
Now I can distribute the two to get 2x squared
plus 2x H plus two h x plus two h squared
minus x minus h plus three, these two terms
are actually the same, I can add them up to
get 4x H. And I think that's as simple as
I can get that part. Now I'm going to write
out F of x plus h minus f of x. So that's
going to be this thing right here, minus f
of x. Again, I need to put the F of X formula
in parentheses to make sure I subtract the
whole thing. I'll distribute the negative.
And now I noticed that a bunch of things cancel
out. So the 2x squared and the minus 2x squared
add to zero, the minus x and the x add to
zero, and the three and the minus three add
to zero. So I'm left with 4x H plus two h
squared minus h. Finally, I'll write out the
whole difference quotient by dividing everything
by H. I can simplify this further, because
notice that there's an H in every single term
of the numerator. If I factor out this H,
H times 4x, plus two h minus one divided by
h, these two H's cancel, and I'm left with
a difference quotient of 4x plus two h minus
one. This difference quotient will become
important in calculus, when we calculate a
difference quotient for smaller and smaller
values of h, eventually letting h go to zero
and ending up with an expression that has
no H's in it and represents the derivative
or slope of the function itself. In this video,
we use the formula f of b minus F of A over
B minus A to calculate an average rate of
change and the related formula f of x plus
h minus f of x over h to calculate and simplify
a difference quotient